je wählenden ja das wort und wir bei
phoenix haben sechs von ihnen begleitet
stellvertretend für alle millionen in
der phönix wahlstraße und es ist so bei
jedem der sechs steht eine andere partei
ganz hoch im kurs und bei uns kommen sie
zusammen zum austausch und zum digitalen
schlagabtausch
[Musik]
über gesagt kompromiss wird immer
schreiben wie kann man sowas erzählt
emotionen ins spiel kommen jetzt halt
unser
verständnis was bin ich vollkommen
verständnislos ein indiskutables thema
waren viele ansicht nur weil ich so
nicht vermutet hätte ja der letzte
konservative am tisch wie sorge ich mich
gefühlt ob er wirklich konservativ ist
wenn er aktiviert oder rechts
ich glaube die spd kommt irgendwo um die
22 25 prozent tatsächlich sind die
sozialen medien mittlerweile die orte in
denen sich die wahlen entscheiden werden
ich bin 31
mein name ist es auch wir sind sechs
leute aus essen werden alle eine andere
partei und diskutieren über alle
möglichen themen zu wollen oder
instagram ja da gibt es dann immer so
einen kleinen schlagabtausch
untereinander digital weil wir ja jeder
eine andere partei wählen werden ob sind
dann so
eine kleine bundestag debatte aber wir
sind heute morgen keine politiker ja das
ist ein wahnsinnig interessant das
projekt die phoenix wallstraße das
findet es für instagram oder auch
fußball sind und auch jetzt ist die
phoenix wahlstraße digital im stream
aber auch bei uns schalten wir jetzt mal
zur zeche zollverein nach essen da ist
meine kollegin jana becker mit den
teilnehmenden aus der wallstraße und
jana bei euch ist das jetzt so dass
jeder der teilnehmenden einer anderen
partei die daumen drückt wie ist es denn
dann so ein wahlabend gemeinsam zu
erleben
die stimmung hier ist erwartungsvoll
zugesagt hat es alle bürger in der
phönix wallstraße haben unterschiedliche
parteien gewählt deswegen werden wir
heute auch noch in den austausch gehen
alle wählenden hier haben in den letzten
drei monaten über unseren phoenix
instagram channel intensiv diskutiert
sich ausgetauscht den wahlkampf
beobachtet und da möchte ich von dir
gehören jetzt mal wissen du hast die spd
gewählt wie war das für dich diese
intensive auseinandersetzung mit den
themen also es war für mich so dass ich
nicht zum ersten weil man irgendwie so
intensiv mit politik beschäftigt haben
jetzt ja in diesen 100 tagen
am anfang stand ich dann so gut dass ich
von hier unten
doch zumindest wenn man dem problem
werden kann man recht warum geändert und
sich deswegen bin ich gespannt was war
damals passiert und wie dann wirklich
nach koalitionen sind in der sz gleich
zu dir du hast die grünen gewählt er
seit jetzt natürlich ziemlich
unterschiedliche persönlichkeiten die ja
auch aufeinander getroffen sind mit
unterschiedlichen haltungen und inhalten
deswegen wie die war der enge austausch
für dich die drei monate über
doch das war sehr interessant also ich
fand es sehr interessant dass man in
vielen dingen dann doch gar nicht so
weit auseinander lag und dass man da
sage ich mal schon auch gemeinsamkeiten
hatte also auch mit allen fand ich jetzt
das weiß nie so dass man wirklich das
ist so richtig knallte sondern dass man
so gemeinsam schon auch den anderen mit
verstanden hat ja selbst gesagt ihr habt
nicht weit auseinander gelegen bei den
meisten themen bei vielen aber doch
andreas du fehlst mir da direkt ein
themen wie die klimadebatte oder auch
die ja die debatte um die um die
regenbogenfarben während der em du hast
jetzt die afg gewählt
wie also was war für dich denn die
hitzige diskussion kannst kannst du dich
da festlegen es gab einige punkte liegen
unterschiedlicher meinung war auch
ziemlich konnte er aber ich denke werden
das gut aus diskutiert und sind am ende
des tages auch in irgendwann zu einem
konsens gekommen wo man auch sagen kann
dass man auch die meinung des anderen
akzeptieren kann und wo man sie nicht
teilt das halte ich für sehr wichtig das
fand ich sehr interessant und die
regenbogen geschichte natürlich ja es
gibt verschiedene sachen wie sehe ich
halt anders aber so ist halt nun mal
halt im leben na ja wie gesagt ziemlich
viele unterschiedliche positionen auch
gehabt auch wenn ihr euch menschlich wie
immer betont habe gut verstanden habe du
bist älteste der runde jetzt gewesen da
möchte ich einmal nach links rüber
schauen zu dir lissa du bis 18 jahre
jungen konnte es jetzt auch das erste
mal an der bundestagswahl teilnehmen
da fällt mir jetzt auch direkt ein also
dass die spd fdp gewählt das wollen wir
zu sagen da fällt dann natürlich jetzt
direkt ein 16 jahre kanzlerin angela
merkel wie ist das jetzt für dich dass
sich das dass ich das ändern du kannst
es ja gar nicht anders ich glaube es ist
sehr ungewohnt ich habe eigentlich nur
angela merkel als kanzlerin erlebt und
ich halte von ihr persönlich sehr viel
aber inhaltlich sind wir doch relativ
weit auseinander
und gerade bei union und spd ja auch so
nah beieinander sind bin ich gespannt
was es wird nur man muss auch ganz klar
sagen angela merkel hat als kanzlerin
sehr viel richtig gemacht auf einer
persönlichen ebene aber beispielsweise
sachen wie klimaschutz einfach
verschlafen und da hoffe ich jetzt auf
einen politikwechsel haben wir noch
alles verstehen die die cdu gewählt
haben aus zeitgründen gehen wir zurück
wollen aber jetzt einmal noch kurz sagen
dass wir gleich in dem auf der phoenix
youtube-seite im livestream zu sehen
sind zwei stunden lang und weiter uns
austauschen werden und natürlich auch
die ersten zahlen der aufnehmen werden
aus berlin vorwärts zurück in
vielen dank an jana becker und die
mitglieder der wallstraße ton probleme
die wir zeitweise hatten bitten wir zu
entschuldigen herr voss wir haben jetzt
gerade in der wallstraße
dort menschen erlebt die schon sehr früh
und sehr klar wussten was sie wählen
wollen man hört dabei immer wieder von
vielen unentschlossenen die quasi erst
in der wahlkabine sich entscheiden wen
sie letztendlich wählen wollen ist eine
längerfristige wähler bindung nicht mehr
das was es heute noch so gibt sie wird
zumindest herausgefordert ich glaube das
prägt eigentlich diesen wahlkampf wenn
wir uns verschiedene umfragezahlen
anschauen dann haben wir bei der
direktwahlfrage am ende eigentlich sehr
deutlich gesehen dass olaf scholz hier
vorne lag wenn wir uns die themen agenda
angucken dann hat dort sozusagen umwelt
klimaschutz dominiert aber es gibt eben
noch viele menschen die vielleicht in
den letzten wahlen immer angela merkel
und die union gewählt haben und diese
menschen die vielleicht stolz als
kanzler umweltpolitik als thema aber
irgendwie auch erfahrung mit der union
haben genau die mussten heute eine für
sie schwierige entscheidungen treffen
wenn sie konnten ja nur eine zweitstimme
vergeben das macht den heutigen wahltag
auch so spannend weil man nicht genau
weiß wie die eigentlich dann in dem
moment in dem sie dann der wahlkabine
standen was in dem moment der
ausschlaggebende faktor war kommt auf
den kanzler kommt auf das thema an kommt
es auf die vergangenheit das was ich
früher gemacht habe die parteibindung
vielleicht an das ist wirklich das was
das so außergewöhnlich macht und das ist
auch der grund warum es durchaus noch
bewegung auf der zielgerade geben kann
wie muss man das bewerten ist dass er
ein zeichen für eine stabile demokratie
oder muss man sich eher sorgen machen
weil die wahlen oder wenn der wahltag
kommt es letztendlich von stimmungen
abhängt dass sich im wahlkampf fast
bewegt finde ich erstmal durch hass
positiv wäre langweilig wenn jede wahl
immer gleiche ausgehen würde dann
könnten wir mal was soll das überhaupt
wir wollen ja genau wandel wir wollen
reaktion auf entwicklung aber es bringt
natürlich herausforderung mit sich
einfach weil stabilität weil so eine
gewisse trägheit im system die natürlich
auch vorzüge hat wenn man über
stabilität kontinuität über viele jahre
und jahrzehnte nachdenkt die das mit
sich bringt das ist nicht mehr so wir
sehen unglaublicher ausschläger auch den
wirklich sehr sehr kurzer sicht das gilt
für die letzten wochen aber wenn man die
letzten zwei jahre sich in umfragen
machen
also herzlich willkommen zum phoenix war
straßen live stream heute bei uns aus
essen wir befinden uns hier auf dem
gelände der zeche zollverein an der
ehemaligen kokerei der zeche mitten im
ruhrgebiet
wir bitten jetzt gerade die tonprobleme
zu entschuldigen die wir hatten bei der
live schalte
nach berlin
das ist jetzt aber geklärt von daher
möchte ich einmal noch herzlich
willkommen sagen und unseren gästen
aus essen aus der phönix wallstraße ihr
habt die letzten 100 tage sehr intensiv
diskutiert über instagram euch
ausgetauscht habe eben schon gesagt den
wahlkampf beobachtet auch eure
persönlichen themen in den fokus bringen
können bei instagram stellt euch auch
gerne einmal persönlich kurz vor wer ihr
seid was ihr gewählt habt jahren fangen
wir doch gerne an ja also mein name ist
ja mittlerweile bin ich 41 jahre alt als
das projekt anschieben weil ich noch
jünger
bin spd-wähler wenn gebürtig aus essen
und habe das ganze projekt
mitgemacht
andreas 59 jahre jeder runde der älteste
stimmt und bin von hause aus diplom
ingenieur waschechtes urgestein
ruhrgebiets pottler und hat das gerne
gemacht hier war sehr viel spaß gemacht
hat und hier zu diesem event zu der
geschickte 12 1 habe ich auch eine
persönliche beziehung
ja ich bin 46 jahre alt und kommt
ursprünglich aus dem saarland das heißt
auch aus der gegend die er momentan
durch die montanindustrie geprägt ist
und fand dieses mal straßenprojekt
einfach total spannend dass sechs
unterschiedliche personen vorstellen
können wie sie zu bestimmten themen
denken und und da auch eine austausch
kommen könnten daher fand ich die die
ziemlich gut
dem bürger zu unserer jüngsten wählerin
der runde
ich bin issa ich bin 18 jahre als ich
bin jurastudentin und ich bin
mittlerweile seit einem jahr in fdp und
seit zwei jahren bei den jungen liebe
rein und habe dementsprechend auch fdp
gewählt
wann die letzte aus mein name ist alles
fertig bin 26 jahre alt ich bin
eigentlich solingerin wohne jetzt seit
ca zwei zweieinhalb jahren in essen und
ja aber die cdu gewählt
danke euch wir stehen jetzt hier mit
fünf personen aus der wallstraße vorher
waren es sechs wer uns vielleicht auch
instagram verfolgt hat hat es gesehen
die die linken gewählt hat kann heute
leider nicht dabei sein zum gruß an der
stelle genau das wird unsere gäste wir
haben jetzt auch noch noch eine person
hier stehen die heute unsere online
kommentare beobachten wird für uns den
blick ins netz
welt am 4
100 zu sein das bedeutet wann immer ihr
etwas sagen und wenn ihr eine frage habt
an einen der bewohner innen oder wenn
ihr einfach nur eure meinung kundtun
wollte wenn euch ein thema wichtig ist
dann schreibt das gerne in die
kommentare
und ich versuche einige eurer frage dann
auch mit aufzunehmen und mich hier in
die runde zu gehen und tatsächlich haben
wir auch schon mal eine umfrage
gestartet auf youtube youtube chad da
seht ihr eine umfrage und zwar lautet
die frage wer wird nachfolger oder
nachfolgerin
nachfolgerin oder nachfolger von
kanzlerin angela merkel eine spannende
frage ich bin gespannt was ihr tipp das
lösen wir dann später auf aber ja ich
glaube ich gibt die frage erst mal eine
runde
wir haben wir nämlich auch was
vorbereitet ich kann das einmal zeigen
ihr habt auf eurem tischen jeweils drei
zettel liegen diese zeit bekommt
zugleich ließ er sie einmal zeigen
die drei
köpfe armin laschet olaf scholz und
annalena baerbock ihr dürft jetzt
entscheiden
welches schild ihr hoch hoch halten
wollte die frage lautet wer wird die
neue bundesregierung anführen
eure tipps
gerne eine eine person einfach
hoch halten wenn ihr alle so weit seid
dann würde ich sagen
mehr was ihr glaubt was wird
da ist wirklich schon
vorbei h ist es okay olaf scholz sehe
ich gleich dreimal
okay da möchte ich natürlich auch noch
mal näher darauf eingehen kurz und
fangen wir bei dir an
die umfragewerte für die grünen waren ja
jetzt nicht
ja nicht nicht mehr so herausragende die
noch vor einigen wochen
wie kommt es dass du frau werbekuchen
[Musik]
glaub ich noch ein annalena baerbock
mal gucken
merck schon da fängt die diskussion
schon dann aber andré also du dich schon
eingeschaltet hat olaf scholz
du wirst ehemaliger cdu hat jahrelang
jetzt cdu bewirbt das dann übergegangen
zu zwei fdp kommt dieser tipp jetzt oder
man muss da ein bisschen realistisch
sein ich denke dass die spd die stärkste
partei wird die stärkste partei versucht
an den kanzler zu stellen wird die
koalitionsverhandlungen machen es wird
sehr interessant weil ja drei parteien
erstmals benötigt werden in diesem jahr
geht es wird wohl so sein und insofern
denke ich realistisch eine
journalistische aus rufes wetterschutz
was haben wir hier jetzt noch hast auch
den oder falls hoch hoch gehoben so die
fdp
das ist wissen wir ja jetzt auch dass
herr lindner er die union wird bevorzugt
zuvor zogen würde über
koalitionsmöglichkeiten sprengen später
nämlich auch noch mal genauer aber warum
warum olaf scholz ich glaube dass wir
einfach eine frage wie wahrscheinlich es
ist und also klar ist auch wenn ich
jetzt leider enttäuschen muss ich glaube
annalena baerbock ist raus aus dem
rennen und olaf scholz liegt aktuell
vorne und ich glaube dass die spd also
ich sage die letzten paar wochen
eigentlich immer die einzigen parteien
die noch wirklich guten wahlkampf
gemacht haben in den letzten paar wochen
waren spd und fdp da bin ich jetzt auch
ein bisschen voreingenommen aber ich
glaube einfach dass der wahlkampf da
noch viel reißen konnte
ja interessant so das war jetzt nicht
allzu überraschend bei dir alles
also du du du glaubst an armin laschet
auch wenn die wenn die umfragewerte
jetzt klar jetzt längere zeit doch
relativ weit unten waren aber den
aufschwung bremst du mit heute.de
aufschwung
beziehungsweise banner schulz ohne
werden das ging ja auch aktuelle so dass
es bald wieder bergauf geht und das
natürlich nicht gut
wir beobachten dass weiter haben
natürlich dann später auch die
aktuellsten zahlen wir sind alle
gespannt auf die prognosen darauf
arbeiten wir jetzt erstmal hin auf 18
uhr
möchte also ich möchte aber gerne noch
mal über das projekt wallstraße mit euch
sprechen ich hatte eben schon gesagt ihr
habt 100 tage lang intensiv diskutiert
ihr wohnt alle ihr lebt alle in essen
du jetzt noch nicht allzu lang aber sie
habe ich es gehört schon schon schon
relativ lange
also etwa drei monate lang teil der der
wallstraße wie habt ihr diesen austausch
lebt fanden wir fangen wir mit dir gerne
gerne nochmal anhören
kommt ja
interessant
wir machen würde mit wem hat es dir aber
am meisten freude gemacht so zu
diskutierenden austausch zu gehen
letztendlich
natürlich ich habe mich ja mal als der
letzten konservativen bezeichnet und das
ist natürlich schon so dass hier meinung
vertreten werden die in diesem sehr
weites spektrum sich bewegen die sind
sehr rechts konservativen spektrum ist
natürlich so und natürlich alle anderen
sind irgendwie links ja oder die
meinungen der parteien das habe ich auch
gesagt jeder am tisch sind sind auch
unterscheiden sich nicht wesentlich es
gibt der konsens ist eigentlich schon
ziemlich da und sofern kein wunder dass
werde ich den meisten differenzen hatten
empfinde ich nicht als dramatisch ist es
kein problem
das finde ich sehr entspannt der
austausch war sehr entspannt die 100
tage waren auch fordern man musste schon
am ball bleiben es kam battles und
battles und alles mögliche musste man
davor erzählt man konnte sich also ein
bisschen entspannen auch im urlaub wurde
man schön getriggert also insofern war
schon angenehme sache
ich war ein bisschen neugierig wie
phoenix dazu macht ist ja ein etwas
neues projekt und da ich mich ja auch
mittlerweile auch im internet bewegung
diese dinge empfinde ich das eine gute
neuerung dass man austausch diese art
und weise etwas lockerer macht und ich
glaube dass man da auch zu konsens
kommen dann so wie es gern beschrieben
hat dass man auch andere meinungen
akzeptieren kann
immer zu dir über alles andreas hat
gerade gesagt die parteien hier am tisch
oder an den vierten mann sagen
sind sich relativ ähnlich so in ihren
positionen und was sagst du auch eher
links würdest du jetzt zu sagen die cdu
also würdest du die cdu verordnen gerade
[Musik]
was manchem vororten andreas sagte
gerade das dass ihr eher ein konsens
gebildet hätte rein thematisch würdest
du sagen weil die cdu würde man jetzt
eher als konservative partei nach
bezeichnet würdest du dem zustimmen oder
wie wie hast du das das erlebt seit ihr
wart ihr in eure position immer eine
sein
ist aber auch gut so deshalb biete auch
jeder eine andere partei und ja das war
so seine richtigkeit und
wir hatten jetzt habe eben schon gesagt
andreas ist der älteste der runde du
bist die die jüngste runde
außerdem bist du eine der
2,8 millionen erst wählerinnen jetzt in
diesem jahr
genau zur bundes zur bundestagswahl was
war was war dein ansporn teil der
wallstraße zu sein warum hast du hast du
mit gemacht ja ich glaube das ist sehr
interessant
erstmal gibt es noch sehr viele
klischees über die fdp und ich glaube
dass ich da tendenziell vielleicht eher
nicht ganz so reinpasse
wir sind sehr beliebt bei jungen
menschen also das passt aber der fdp
wird ja sehr oft vorgeworfen sich keine
frauen dabei haben wir sehr viele
spitzenpolitikerin die sehr gut sind und
ich würde also ich wollte im kern
einfach die klischees entkräften und
auch
beispielsweise wenn man sich mit anderen
leuten unterhält dann kommen ja auch
immer so floskeln wie ach ja die fdp
wäre sowieso dass das der markt regelt
und in
teils stimmt das natürlich aber das ist
schon sehr extrem beschrieben und ich
glaube ich könnte diese klischees ein
bisschen entkräften du bist
ja also wie gesagt ist noch relativ jung
interessant das ist so früh auch
politische themen interessiert hast du
das gefühl das ist jetzt auch eine
generation deine generation ist eine
generation die jetzt politisch
interessiert hat vielleicht auch aktiver
ist
ich weiß nicht also ich glaube ich habe
keinen vergleich zu anderen generationen
aber ich merke auf jeden fall dass alle
meine freunde auch die die sich vor der
bundestagswahl nicht so sehr für politik
interessiert haben die zumindest mal
gefragt haben wofür steht die fdp oder
bei anderen freunden wofür stehen die
grünen und ich kenne kaum leute die
zumindest nicht wählen gegangen sind und
ich kann auch eigentlich niemanden der
nicht demokratisch gewählt hat also auf
jeden fall also eine politisch
interessierte generation oder zumindest
eine politisch interessierte menschen
mit denen du dich umgibt sagen ja genau
natürlich kann man auch auf dienstag
haben jetzt noch jederzeit nach schon
was ihr da so betrieben habt einfach in
unserem phoenix instagram channel den
feed mal durch scrollen oder auch in die
highlights gucken da kann man alles
alles nachsehen was in den letzten
einhundert tagen passiert ist außerdem
haben wir von phoenix unsere wahl
straßen bewohner innen auch noch
zusätzlich begleitet und haben eine doku
ausgemacht mein kollege david dampfen
und ich genau haben mit euch gesprochen
zwischendurch und geschaut was ihre was
was ihr da so so so treibt das könnt ihr
jederzeit auch nachschauen wer interesse
hat in den mediatheken und den link
werdet ihr auch ins unter dem youtube
und unter unserem youtube live stream
auch gleich finden gerne drauf klicken
wer lust hat
genau
wir haben jetzt
so viele themen gehabt die letzten
wochen monate wahlkampf
jede person was von euch hatte andere
ja also den größere größere interessen
würde jetzt mal estelle dich fragen was
war dein größeres thema ich bin nicht
sicher ob es uns überraschen wird
ist die wallstraße beginn begann hatte
ich die klimakrise genannt und der
erhalt der demokratie und das muss man
schon von diesem wahlkampf sagen dass
dieses thema wirklich das all
dominierende thema geworden ist also
keine einzige partei
demokratische partei kommt jetzt um
dieses thema krise klimakrise drumherum
und das allein finde ich schon ein
wahnsinniger erfolg dieses gesamten
wahlkampf ist also das finde ich da bin
ich schon sehr zufrieden
man muss jetzt auch sagen auch andere
parteien
hast du gerade gesagt haben jetzt das
thema klima auf dem zettel in den
wahlprogrammen die cdu zum beispiel ist
jetzt im nachhinein noch ja vor
gepressten muss man sagen mit einem mit
einem klima paket ihr haben turbo für
die erneuerbaren genannt da hat jetzt
der grünen bundesgeschäftsführer kellner
gesagt ist super wenn die anderen
parteien unser unser programm
abschreiben ist das so super auch für
die für die für die zahlen
für die für die grünen was das
wahlergebnis jetzt angehen könnte ist es
jetzt auch als clown die anderen
parteien vielleicht den grünen ihr thema
also abschreiben können die natürlich
alle sehr sehr gerne das ist ja schön
und so soll es ja auch sein dass
möglichst alle dieses thema jetzt in den
vordergrund rücken aber man hat ja die
parteiprogramme verglichen und
herausgekommen ist dass es da schon sehr
sehr große differenzen gibt also dass
das programm der grünen mit abstand am
an ernsten das 15 grad ziel erreichen
wird und von daher sehe ich da
eigentlich von den anderen parteien was
sie jetzt reden und sagen überhaupt
keine konkurrenz zumal die ja auch
eigentlich 16 jahre vollzeit hatten sich
dazu bewegen und das jetzt sage ich mal
im rahmen eines
einer
von von fahrt von war das jetzt zu
nennen ist es nett und schön und es ist
gut dass es da auch angekommen ist aber
ich nehme es den dann trotzdem nicht ab
cdu angesprochen
alles da fällt der ball kauf des
klimaschutzes spielt jetzt auch in
umfragen oder spielt eine große rolle
bei der frage jetzt was die wähler innen
so bewegt auch im vorfeld der
bundestagswahl
klima nimmt viel fläche ein du hast
gesagt in einem instagram kurs erinnere
ich mich daran wir hatten auch schon
viel früher mehr für den klimaschutz tun
können jetzt war die cdu lange an der
regierung
es ist ja genug passiert es hätte mehr
passieren können
klima ist ein riesenthema ja aber wir
hatten die letzten 16 jahre weitaus
andere größere themen sag ich mal wir
hatten die finanzkrise die
flüchtlingskrise und die haben das gut
gemeistert ja und klima hat nie mehr
einbringen können aber das ist
vergangenheit ich schaue nach vorne und
hoffe da kommt mir also hast du jetzt
das gefühl den cdu tut genug beim thema
klimaschutz
ich bin gespannt na also die letzten 16
jahre nicht so viel aber ich bin
zuversichtlich
ein positiver blick in die zukunft okay
geben wir noch mal in die andere andere
ecke auch zum thema klima gerne wie die
sich so wie die spd da aufgestellt auch
mit einem möglichen kanzler scholz ich
mein man darf nicht außer acht lassen
dass die spd auch in den letzten jahren
oftmals mit einer regierung drin saß und
auch da dann definitiv zu wenig fürs
klima gemacht hat ich glaube ich hab's
auch in einem instagram post gesagt ich
glaube deutschland kann mehr als diese
pariser klima ziele umzusetzen und das
glaube ich auch nach wie vor noch also
wenn wir uns alle am riemen reißen ist
das sicherlich etwas was wir alle
umsetzen können und es ist nicht fünf
vor zwölf ist es wahrscheinlich schon
zwei minuten nach 12 und das muss auch
nicht nur jetzt im wahlkampf gelebt
werden sondern halt wirklich auch von
uns jeden umgesetzt werden
das interessant auch dass ihr in vielen
bei vielen themen das ist mir
aufgefallen mich würde jetzt nicht sagen
großartig abweicht von dem
parteiprogramm aber doch ja mehr fordert
würde würde ich mal sagen in vielen
punkten mehr mehr fordert so wie du auch
beim thema im sozialpolitik als es ist
um den mindestlohn gehen wo scholz sagt
wenn ich kanzler werde 12 euro hattest
du auch gesagt ich kann mir auch
mindestlohn von 16 oder oder mehr
vorstellen gibt es geht geht das für
dich dich zusammen somit mit mit der
partei dann trotzdem also was ist ein
ansporn mit einer stimme für die für die
spd ist die frage was die anderen
parteien in dem moment wollen also dass
das einzigste alternativangebot was den
mindestlohn jetzt angeht ist dann glaube
ich bei 12 eur 50 von den linken gewesen
was er jetzt auch 50 cent in einer
stunde mehr also ich glaube egal ob 12
euro 12 euro 50 oder 13 euro mit so viel
geld als stunden und kann man halt
einfach keine bäume ausreißen und jeder
der ordentlich arbeitet hat dafür
ordentliches geld verdient und soll dann
auch ordentlich bezahlt werden und
deswegen finde ich einfach ja 12 euro
ist schon definitiv besser als das was
wir jetzt haben aber ja jeder soll von
seinem geld leben können und nicht nur
irgendwie im zweitjob sich suchen müssen
oder stütze beantragen müssen wie auch
immer so das finde ich einfach ungerecht
dass jetzt gerade auch die die linken
schon angesprochen habe ich einmal kurz
sagen das iza die auch teil der
wallstraße
ist heute leider verhindert ist und
deswegen nicht mit uns hier stehen kann
genau deswegen sind wir auch nur oder
seid ihr zu fünft heute und wer sich
jetzt auch noch wundert warum noch drei
personen mehr hier stehen das sind gäste
die genau die ihr mitgebracht habt auch
noch mal willkommen an der stelle
andreas
es gab viele viele themen manche themen
haben sich weniger interessiert oder
sind auch nicht still stehen auch jetzt
nicht nicht im wahlprogramm oder die fdp
hat hat klima zum beispiel nicht so auf
dem zettel wie die anderen oder leute
sagt zumindest dass es den
menschengemachten klimawandel nicht gibt
welche themen oder welches thema war dir
denn besonders wichtig oder ist die im
wahlkampf im sommer sechs menschen
gemachten klimawandel ich glaube ich
nicht drin es sei die frage wie groß der
ist wie nachhaltig etwas daran ändern
kann das ist lobby er das thema aber
irgendwie schwanken dann vom langen
schwanke ist richtig aber sowieso man
leuten würde man die geschichte nicht
dass wenn ich richtig aber sehr sehr
wichtig ist mir zum beispiel aus dem
kraftwerksbereich wo ich herkomme da
kenne ich mich aus dem
ersten halbjahr 2009 21 56 prozent aus
den konventionellen energien erzeugt
worden weil sich im frühjahr die sonne
und wind nicht so gezeigt hat wie in den
letzten jahren was ja auch passieren
kann auch schwankungen und wenn ich mir
jetzt einfach noch vorstellen oder wir
alle irgendwo den nächsten jahren
elektroauto fahren wollen da kommen wir
den 56 prozent der wahrscheinlich gar
nicht hin da würde mich schon
interessieren wie dann die lösung
aussehen soll ich als ingenieur
interessiere mich dafür die physik wie
wird die physikalische das mathematische
ersatzmodell dafür sein dass wir das
schaffen können müssen wir jetzt ein
viertel der fläche mit den propellern zu
pflastern die aber dann die sich ja auch
nicht drehen das würde mich
interessieren diese diskussion der gute
wille ist klar er verstehe ich es
nachvollziehbar ich würde auch wenn ich
mich dafür dass sie immer die grünen
wählen weil da ist ein original warum
soll ich jetzt die anderen parteien dann
wählen das würde ich schon so sehen aber
ich denke der lösungsansatz hier wäre
wichtig würde mich interessieren ich
habe keinen dazu
würde mich sehr interessieren
aber es ist das trotzdem thema für dich
für dich persönlich also vielleicht auch
noch mal die die frage so weil ich
gerade auch gesagt hatte ihr seid
teilweise auch ein bisschen abgewichen
von dem was du was die partei wofür die
partei oder bei welchen zahlen die
preise was bringt es uns bei dir also
für mich ist der klimawandel nicht sehr
große thema ich denke dass wir ganz
andere probleme haben oder haben werden
und deswegen ja wie gesagt die
rentenbeiträge und ähnliche dinge ist
für mich jetzt interessant nicht mit 950
jahre ich werde nicht mehr ewig machen
ich muss zwar auf lage nicht darauf
angewiesen zu sein weil ich jahrelang
auch selbständig war aber sicherlich ein
thema für die meisten wir sehen alte
leute die flaschen sammeln und ähnliches
in der gesellschaft ist eine große
spaltung eingetreten jetzt auch in den
letzten anderthalb jahren sicherlich da
denke ich diesen hebel anzusetzen ist
natürlich viel viel schwieriger ich habe
auch nicht eine lösung parat jetzt
machen wir also und die sache ist
erledigt diese dinge sehe ich
vordringlich die kann man kurzfristig
lösen wenn man will und diese
klimawandel geschichte
selbstverständlich ist ein langläufer da
kommt man nicht von heute auf morgen mit
denen okay vom baum der erkenntnis zu
naschen ist die eine geschichte aber wie
komme ich dann effektiv dahin ist die
zweite sache
andreas entgegnen oder
ich finde das ist schon ein bisschen zu
weit gedacht also was für mich schon mal
wichtig ist ist erstmal zu erkennen wir
haben eine klimakrise und sie ist da und
dann zu sagen ja ich habe noch nicht die
phantasie zu sehen wie man das löst das
ist das zweite aber der erste schritt
ist jetzt zu sagen wir haben eine
klimakrise sie ist da wir haben sie
diesen sommer erlebt und wir wissen was
sie bedeutet nämlich 30 milliarden an
steuergeldern einfach nur
wiederaufbaukosten die uns jetzt schon
hier als steuerzahler in deutschland
belasten und es werden immer mehr werden
wenn wir jetzt nicht gegensteuern und
jetzt nicht erkennen wir müssen
unbedingt handeln so und wenn man sagt
ich habe die fantasie nicht wie es geht
also da gibt es ja experten es gibt
jetzt zum beispiel auch gerade gibt es
eine ngo die heißt germany zero die hat
ein gesetzesentwurf ein gesetzespaket
entworfen die letzten zwei drei jahre
das ist fertig sobald diese
bundesregierung gegründet es kann die
eigentlich sich dieses gesetzespaket auf
den tisch legen das in seinen gang
bringen und für maschinen innerhalb der
ersten 100 tage unterstehende lösungen
und maßnahmen drin das heißt ich würde
das jetzt gar nicht mal so negativ sehen
sondern die erkenntnis auch von afg
seite zu sagen ja die klimakrise ist da
und wir müssen was dagegen tun das wäre
ja schon mal ist ja schon mal ein super
anfang
wie es auch häufig in
instagram post auch zur zu erkennen war
wobei ihr euch wirklich also ihr habt ja
auch mal gesagt menschlich sehr ja
anscheinend auch sehr sehr möge von
daher auf einer guten diskussions ebene
was was inhalt agiert
lister nochmal nochmal zu dir die fdp
also du willst du jetzt die fdp
große themen der fdp was waren für dich
jetzt so die großen großen themen im
wahlkampf
generell würde ich auf jeden fall schon
mal zustimmen natürlich auch klimaschutz
ich finde es auch interessant die fdp
hat eben also sie sitzt nicht nur
irgendwo in der ecke und sagt okay ja
mal sehen was wir machen können wir
haben auch ein klimaschutzprogramm was
gerade auch von seiten der grün sehr
kritisch beäugt wurde weil die ansätze
eben
doch sehr
konträr sind aber natürlich auch für
mich als junge personen sachen wie
generationengerechtigkeit das hängt auch
mit dem klima zusammen aber natürlich
auch mit unseren finanzen also die
schulden die wir jetzt unnötigerweise
verbraten sag ich mal es gibt ja
nachhaltige investitionen und nicht
nachhaltige investitionen wie zum
beispiel
subventionen in milliardenhöhe
das gehört auch zur
generationengerechtigkeit aber auch so
sachen wie
gesundheitspolitik einfach weil ich der
meinung bin man sollte nicht immer nur
für seine eigenen also klar ich kann
auch krank werden aber insbesondere mit
hinblick auf die älteren leute weil ich
der meinung bin man sollte nicht immer
nur seine eigenen interessen beim wm
vertreten sondern auch möglichst die der
breiten gesellschaft
hattest du das gefühl dass du die
anderen
teilweise auch mit deinen inhalten
deinen themen überzeugen kommt es in den
in den diskussionen oder war das
tatsächlich eher so ein austausch wo du
sagst war interessant aber da bleibt
jetzt auch nicht vielleicht nicht nicht
so viel hängen also ich muss erst mal
sagen ich glaube es war beidseitig ich
habe auch sehr viel gelernt aber als ich
beispielsweise mit es sei über das klima
über den klimaschutz diskutiert habe
waren wir uns auch hinterher einig okay
also ich glaube man kann sich schon ein
stück weit
entgegen treten und die fdp setzt ja
beispielsweise sehr auf die wirtschaft
in sachen klimaschutz private
investitionen beispielsweise und da
haben wir auf jeden fall schon
kompromisse gefunden auch wenn man
vielleicht nicht komplett auf einen
länder kommt kompromisse werden auch
später wenn die ersten zahlen
daraus sind die erste ersten prognosen
auch noch über mögliche koalition
möglichkeiten sprechen dass dann aber
später noch in einem livestream
alles hast du das gefühl du konnte es
irgendeine person aus dem kreis von von
irgendeiner sache überzeugen die
vielleicht vorher noch nicht so
angekommen
ich sehe schon den grinsenden gesichtern
ein
anscheinend nicht
mehr anscheinend tatsächlich nicht ich
glaube nicht dass ich hier irgendjemand
überzeugen konnte von uns oder von euch
5 leider
ja gut und hier weit und wird am
kandidaten oder ein parteiprogramm
dann frage ich mal andersrum was denn
bei dir so dass du warst gehört hast
post von den anderen gelesen gesehen
hast wo du dann dachte es ja das nehme
ich jetzt für mich auch an oder das was
dran ist gleich nicht die cdu oder da
dann doch falsch und gab es momente es
gab momente ja das thema am
flugkatastrophe
das thema gab ich glaube da hat jeder
von uns noch mal darüber nachgedacht ob
das richtig ist die partei zu wählen die
wir wählen und habe mir zu dem zeitpunkt
auch gerne es teils post angeguckt und
mir wirklich darüber gedanken gemacht
also doch hat dieser reger austausch
auch den ein oder anderen wohl zum
nachdenken gebracht wir beobachten auch
eure fragen die ihr habt die ihr unten
in die kommentare stellen könnt und
unserem youtube unter unserem youtube
live stream
da möchte ich jetzt einmal auf matthias
noch einmal hinweisen
der auch fragen sammeln
dank ja super spannende diskussion hier
und die verfolgt ja auf jeden fall
online genauso ich bin aber noch ein
ergebnis schuldig
unsere youtube community glaubt zu 59%
des olaf scholz heute das ding machen
wird armin laschet folgt dann mit
leichtem abstand oder etwas größerem mit
26 und
annalena baerbock glauben 14 prozent von
euch dass die heute kanzlerin wird ja
und es kam auch einige fragen rhein erst
mal vielleicht zur erklärung warum wir
am anfang viele mikros gleichzeitig zu
sehen hatten es lag an diesen
tonprobleme ich hoffe wir haben uns
mittlerweile ganz gut gelöst und eine
frage die tatsächlich rein kam die geht
so in richtung andreas andreas das haben
sich jetzt kam auch fragen für ist
kantonaler jemand so zur sl und alyssa
aber eine frage die tatsächlich nicht
nur hier heute im schatten gestellt
worden ist sondern auch relativ häufig
bei instagram gestellt worden ist war
wie kannst du eine partei wählen wo
politiker innen auch dabei sind die am
rechten rand er das spektrum stehen
werde ich mal zu dir über vielleicht
kannst du kannst du uns das beantworten
ja das stört mich nicht in der partei
und der parteien fächer gibt es rechte
ganz rechte parteien es gibt auch linke
parteien ist dürfen nicht rechtsextrem
ist auf und linksextremen sein und so
ist es auch im bundestag nicht und so
während die parteien nicht zugelassen
insofern denke ich dass dieses prädikat
rechts
mittlerweile etwas anders gesehen wird
als links also die ausgeglichenheit es
nicht mehr da man sieht dass hier auch
relativ deutlich wie ich es schon mal
gesagt habe bei den anderen parteien es
ist eine konzentration er mag ich will
dass ich will jetzt nicht mit der npd
mit der neuen einheitspartei
deutschlands anfangen aber es ist sehr
viel auch im bundestag sehr viel konsens
in diesen parteien uns um die sache geht
und wir stehen da ziemlich alleine da
von hfd das ist früher anders gewesen
war ausgeglichen gerade war der cdu ist
es so gewesen dass es da auch aus der
csu seite eben eine konservativere hart
gab der ein widerpart gegeben hat unterm
strich hat man sich dann eben
demokratisch geeinigt und diese sache
ist im moment verloren gegangen ich weiß
ja nicht die cdu sich wieder neu
ausrichtet ich denke dass man wird sehen
ob sie eine regierung sieht sich neu
ausrichten sie werden es wieder in eine
konservative richtung machen müssen ganz
klar die frage die ich mich die ich mir
dabei stelle jetzt wenn ich das weiter
gehe das fragt zum beispiel auch ein
user glaubst du denn dass die partei
dein interessen wirklich vertritt und
bis wo ist für dich denn konservativ und
wo hört konservativ für dich auf und
geht dann vielleicht doch ein bisschen
zu weit in die ecke
für mich ist die ganze rechts ist für
mich rechts und rechts konservativ ist
für mich fast ein begriff der
deckungsgleich ist und rechts ist
natürlich ja
rechtsradikal dieser definition könnte
man jetzt im google entsprechend da sehe
ich die partei aber keins in keinster
weise es gibt vielleicht den einen oder
anderen ausleger der schon mal einen
raushaut war früher gang und gäbe heute
ist das natürlich in der zeit etwas
anders sehe ich nicht als drama also für
mich ich werde sehr gut vertreten mit
konservativen meinungen und ich habe da
auch keine berührungsängste
estelle vielleicht gehe ich weg zu dir
weiter denn ist fragen sich einige
menschen warum überhaupt sozusagen die
ard in diesem spektrum hier verteilt ist
wir sagen ganz klar bei phoenix wir
zeigen alle parteien alle großen
fraktionsstärke vertretenen parteien des
bundestages deswegen ist natürlich auch
die fdp dabei aber viele user innen
haben gesagt oder sie konnten nicht ganz
verstehen warum man denn die acht die
zeigt wie war dein eindruck wie war denn
deine
wie kannst du die diskussion vor allem
mit andreas
also ich würde das gerne in zwei
liedern und zwei ich glaube jeder hatte
oder viele von uns haben den wahlomat
gemacht und wenn man sich den wahlomat
anschaut dann wären ja die parteien
aufgezeigt und aufgelistet und an
dritter stelle
an dritter stelle war die afd und ich
war schockiert und ich hab mir gedacht
warum ist die an dritter stelle
ganz einfach auch das ist geregelt beim
wahl o mat ist nicht einfach so die
suchen sich nicht einfach eine partei
aus sondern sie gehen nach
fraktionsstärke bei der letzten
bundestagswahl das heißt da haben wir
schon sage ich mal
ja so ein gleichgewicht in diese
richtung
und mit andreas möchte ich sagen und das
möchte ich gerne nochmal entkoppeln
also ich würde gerne noch mal sagen dass
die die beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz der afd der ist nur
verschoben worden es kommt aber noch es
ist ein urteil nach der wahl soll das
erst stattfinden aber
das ist es gibt parteiangehörige die
definitiv beobachtet werden sollen und
natürlich koppel ich da den andreas von
ab und da sind wir wieder bei dem thema
gesellschaft und und vielfalt also wir
hatten auch während der wallstraße viel
über facebook gesprochen und will man
wenn man diese diskussionen sie die da
stattfinden und wie wie enthemmt das
stattfindet dann würde ich sagen mensch
leute setzt euch doch lieber mal
zusammen spricht lieber man miteinander
redet miteinander und vielleicht kann
man sich da tatsächlich
annähern oder sie nach münster ist ja
auch nur ein mensch dahinter anstatt
sich dann mit so vielen negativen
kommentaren zu ballern also
das sind das in zweiter und und ich
meine wir hatten ja auch hier mal das
essen und da sind wir ja auch gerade
beim klimaschutz damals auf das thema
gekommen dass andreas ja auch sagte ja
es ist auch ein sehr wichtiges thema und
dann haben wir auch zugeprostet also
wenn man dahin kommt finde ich das ist
doch hervorragend ist wunderbar ich
glaube das zeigt tatsächlich die stärke
dieses formates der phoenix waldstraße
tatsächlich die wir auch instagram irrt
seit 100 tagen begleitet haben 66
wählende nämlich die stärke dass wir
alle miteinander ins gespräch gekommen
seid das format was ist gerade das ist
der grat gesprochen hat heißt häppchen
und eingemachtes das gibt es auch hier
auf youtube in unserem channel das könnt
ihr euch gerne anschauen vier sehr sehr
spannende folgen es geht um hartz iv es
geht um angela merkel es geht um das
grundeinkommen also die verschiedensten
themen und natürlich auch ins klima und
dazu gibt es auch eine frage vielleicht
wen haben wir denn lange nicht mehr
vielleicht meinen die andere seite
besser ist kam die frage auf dass das
thema klima krise in letzter zeit
vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so dynamisch
angegangen wird ein bisschen
eingeschlafen ist in unserer regierung
vor dem chat erwähnt wie siehst du das
wie glaubst du dass man das thema wie
man dem haben wieder ein bisschen dampf
einbringen könnte also ich glaube so
oder so ist es ja sehr wahrscheinlich
dass sowohl grüne als auch die fdp in
der nächsten regierung beteiligt sein
werden außer es gibt irgendwo eine
mehrheit für rot-rot-grün oder man
entscheidet sich was ich nicht glaube
für kenia und
ich glaube dass die parteien da oder ich
würde grüne und spd jetzt sehr ähnlich
verorten was das klimaschutzprogramm
angeht ich habe das gefühl die spd ist
da also das ist weniger wirksam und ich
glaube dadurch dass die fdp eben so
einen konträren ansatz hat zu den grünen
kann man da auch sehr gut kompromisse
finden und
allein durch die verschiedenen ansätze
hat man auch schon eine sehr rege
diskussion bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen
ansonsten hatten wir gerade auf youtube
auch noch die umfrage wie die menschen
denken gewählt haben und sehr spannender
weise okay es hat sich jetzt just in
diesem moment verändert aber nur zu 51
zu 49 prozent also gesamtsituation
briefwahl und wählen im wahllokal und
vielleicht gebe ich diese frage einfach
mal in die breite runde und frage mal
mit einem handzeichen wer von euch hat
sap brief gewählt
hat darf sich auch melden als man glaube
ich vier und werfen wahllokal heute
gewählt weil 45 ja das ist ja fast
ausgeglichen und damit würde ich sagen
ja gebe ich wieder zu dir und wie
spannende runde
vielleicht können wir auch zum thema
briefwahl einmal noch noch noch
anknüpfen weil jetzt natürlich auch
durch corona der anteil an menschen die
jetzt per briefwahl abstimmen
auch höher war heute
die wahlbeteiligung war dennoch in den
in vielen wahllokalen vormittags schon
sehr sehr sehr hoch aber
die frage warum
ja war warum briefwahl
bei mir war es ganz einfach ich habe zur
europawahl so lange in der schlange
gestanden dass ich mir gesagt ob ich
möchte das nicht mehr und ich bin zwar
doppelt geimpft aber trotzdem sind wir
in einer pandemie und für mich stand ja
schon fest was ich wählen möchte und
dann muss ich nicht bis zur letzten
sekunde warten und deswegen habe ich
mich für eine briefwahl entschlossen ein
wahltag ist ja also man kennt es von
früher wahrscheinlich noch mehr als ich
wir gehen jetzt ins wahllokal und es ist
wahrscheinlich außer sonntags event wir
haben
wie war das war das war das bei dir
jetzt ist es aus alter gewohnheit ist
jetzt heute so gewesen hast du ins
wahllokal gegangen also ich würde jetzt
nicht von von einem event reden ich weiß
aber dadurch dass ich selber mal
wahlhelfer war wie langweilig es sein
kann wenn keiner vorbeikommt zum wählen
und tatsächlich war das der einzige
grund warum ich im wahllokal wählen war
damit die jungs und mädels die da sitzen
einfach ein bisschen was zu tun haben
und größen wir hiermit auch alle
wahlhelfer wahlhelfer hin machen
man muss ja nicht die einzigen sein die
heute arbeiten
jetzt noch mal geschaut auf den
wahlkampf insgesamt da war viel los also
es war auch nicht nur thematisch viel
los sondern es wurde sich auch
an personen abgearbeitet könnte man
könne man vielleicht schon schon so
sagen
warum
das war jetzt gar nicht auf die frage
bezogen einfach ich wollte jetzt noch
die übrigen 15 minuten die wir haben
annalena baerbock nochmal in den
vordergrund rücken aber zum wahlkampf
selber
habe also wirklich für mich persönlich
gefühlt war das ein unheimlich
aggressiver wahlkampf ich kam mir ganz
oft auch an so amerika heimische
verhältnisse
erinnert vor ich fand es war kein
schöner wahlkampf man hat sich mehr an
an lästereien abgearbeitet ich hätte mir
mehr inhalte gewünscht auch grad am
anfang und
ja also definitiv wünsche ich mir da
eine andere wahlkampf kultur auch medial
muss ich zugeben
das fand ich sehr schade und
ja das ist so mein fazit von diesem
wahlkampf was hat sich da am meisten
geärgert
also wirklich dass man nicht die inhalte
in den vordergrund gerückt hat sondern
und und auch jetzt am ende die tri ace
die wahlkampfarena
viel zu viel viel zu viel anstatt zum
beispiel mir hätte es mir gebracht oder
vielleicht auch allen anderen
aus den wahlprogrammen sachen zu
vergleichen zu berichten darüber
frühzeitig und nicht in letzter sekunde
also jetzt wurde wirklich in den in den
letzten wochen alles abgerockt teilweise
waren die tri elle voller themen aber
die dort es sich auch beschweren dass es
kamen keine richtige bett ist zustande
sondern die kandidaten muss nur ein
thema nach dem anderen abarbeiten und am
ende standen war da und fanden die
sendung eigentlich total langweilig weil
irgendwie nichts mehr hin geblieben ist
und da hätte ich mir wirklich mehr
wirklich inhaltlich ist schon sehr früh
gewünscht und und dann wenige kurze
debatten mit den kandidaten und
und wie gesagt weniger auf kleinigkeiten
wie zippel der rock hier und
da fand ich manchmal wirklich
meisterhaft ja es war ein letzter
haffter wahlkampf das würde ich so
zusammenfassen für mich noch vielleicht
eine frage bevor wir auch gleich mal
hören wollen was ihr jetzt heute tipp
für den ausgang ausgang der wahl
alles halt dich noch mal gefragt was was
war für dich gab es gab es ein paar
positiv gesprochen gab es ein highlight
in den wahlkampf
ich muss gerade überlegen
sein sondern auch eine antwort
eigentlich kann ich das teil nur recht
geben
und ich habe ich jetzt wenig mitgenommen
naja soviel lästerei
viel gesetze es wurde viel gesprochen
aber wenig gesagt also inhaltlich war
noch nicht viel und ich
positive highlights
konnte jetzt nicht viel mitnehmen so
[Gelächter]
wir haben euch
vor
100 tagen gefragt als die wallstraße
begonnen hat was treibt ihr wie wird
eure partei beim
waldtag dastehen weil
ja wie werden die die zahlen aussehen
und da möchte ich euch jetzt heute
fragen kurz bevor die die zahlen die
ersten prognosen rauskommen was tippt
ihr heute würde jetzt gerne auch bei dir
behörden anfangen einmal die runde
machen was ihr denkt was eure partei
heute für vier prozent
herausholen kann spd dann würde ich
heute 25,6 prozent sein 25,6 spd sagte
ohne komma 11
11 prozent 11% afd deinen tipp grünen
positiv klar ich hab mit
22,5
22,4 wolke deutlich mehr als jetzt in
den umfragen bisher die grünen da
standen jetzt die letzten tage
fdp ich war eigentlich 11 tippen aber
ich bin überzeugt oder ich möchte gerne
ist die ersten vier plätze an
demokratischen parteien gehen deswegen
dann bleibt noch die der cdu ich wollte
eigentlich 25 prozent sagen aber da der
behörden gesagt hat 25,60 spd sage ich
dann natürlich 26 prozent
das archiv vor einem wettbewerb aus aber
die erste erste erste stimme zählt da
gebe ich doch mal gerne direkt rüber zu
matthias wieder der auch den vergleich
anstellen kann so ist das wir haben hier
unsere wunderschöne flipchart vielleicht
hat der ein oder andere sie feiern schon
im hintergrund bei mir gesehen ist fehlt
noch ein ergebnis aber das habe ich auch
eingeholt die gute idee die die linken
wählt hat gesagt die linken schaffens
knapp und kommen mit 6 1 ja wir haben
auch zwölf minuten bis die ersten
prognosen da sind bis die ersten
prognosen ankommen aber vielleicht die
menschen die uns auf dem programm folgen
die kennt schon diesen ganzes
marienkäfer ihr kennt ihn auf jeden fall
auch in diese marienkäfer haben unsere
sechs nämlich vor 100 tagen getippt wie
viel prozent die jeweiligen parteien
holen und das wollen wir jetzt mal
auflösen und sind wir mal gespannt ob
sie jetzt nah dran sind und dann sind
wir auch gespannt ob sie nach 18 uhr
noch nah dran sind also alisa heutige
tipp 26 prozent vor 100 tagen was ihnen
ganz kleines bisschen hoffnungsvoller da
hat sie auf 28 prozent getippt aber
danach ist ja auch noch einiges passiert
andreas auch er war hoffnungsvoller noch
vor 100 tagen
andreas hat 100 tagen gesagt die afg
holt
13,5 prozent auch da ist man schon ein
bisschen runtergegangen
dann haben wir den björn der björn hat
seine entscheidung ein bisschen
verändert aber auf 100 tagen saß für die
spd nun wirklich auch ganz schön anders
außer den umfragen björn hat aus 25 6
prozent heute damals 22 prozent getippt
dann haben wir es hell die heute schon
leicht über den letzten umfragewerten
steht und damals vor 100 tagen waren wir
aber ja gerade in einer relativen
hochphase tatsächlich nicht schockiert
sein oder überrascht sein sl hat damals
auf 35 prozent getippt also auf jeden
fall stärkste kraft wäre das geworden
damals dann haben wir die liste heute
mit 12 prozent aber hat sie ja
eigentlich nur getippt um ein bisschen
höher zu liegen vom andreas denn vor 100
tagen sie es eigentlich gleich geblieben
hat sich schon auf die elf prozent
gelähmt tipp mal gucken was später
rauskommt und last but not least isa von
den linken die hat gar keine zahl
aufgeschrieben wird verschieben die
linke wird stimme sich vor der fdp
liegen ich würde sagen auch da hat sich
in ihrem tipp auf jeden fall schon etwas
verändert sätzen mit 6 prozent liegt sie
auf jeden fall deutlich dahinter und das
ist dass das kann man gar nicht gut aus
schreiben das ist das was wir bis jetzt
wissen und jetzt dauert es noch knappe
zehn minuten dann haben wir auch die
erste prognose und auch ein chat könnt
ihr sehr sehr gerne natürlich weiter
schreiben was ihr alle so tippt
ansonsten zum thema übrigens lange
schlangen libyen hat gesagt deswegen ist
heute wegen gegangen weil er wollte den
jungs und mädels in den wahllokalen auch
ein bisschen arbeit geben und das
scheint sich auch ein bisschen zu zeigen
denn in berlin gibt es auf jeden fall
ein paar längere warteschlangen vor den
wahllokalen so dass da die wahllokale
sogar nach 18 uhr noch geöffnet sind so
dass mit alle wählen können die
zumindest davor stehen liegt aber an
wohl ein unter anderem problem was es da
gab ja und damit haben wir glaube ich
einen ganz guten überblick bekommen
und vielleicht gebe ich mit einer frage
noch mal in die runde
jana damit kannst du dann machen was du
möchtest mit dieser frage und zwar hat
er zog ich gerade nach dem namen der mir
entfallen ist ich will aber den namen
noch dazu sagen es war glaube ich eben
manuell nähe von rom roger rabbit hat's
gefragt toller name ob ihr denn glaubt
dass mit ihr mit eurer stimmabgabe genug
demokratische kraft ins parlament
gegeben habt und ob ihr euch
demokratisch vertreten fühlt oder ob er
glaubt dass wir vielleicht andere
beteiligungsformen brauchen
ja da
das ist eine wirklich tolle frage weil
ich finde demokratie besteht nicht darin
dass ich alle vier jahre wählen gehe
meinen zettel einsteck und hause geht
und das haben wir jetzt hier auch in der
wallstraße sehr sehr gut gemacht oder
erlebt auch nämlich dass das demokratie
ist also wir als bürger sind ja auch ein
teil der demokratie das heißt wir müssen
auch überprüfen was diejenigen die wir
gewählt haben was sie so machen damit
wir nämlich nicht nur vier jahren
dastehen und uns fragen ja was ist denn
eigentlich passiert und wenn wenig denn
jetzt also von daher sind wir eigentlich
als als bürger einer demokratie stets
und andauernd markt und
es gibt oder gerade mein thema war ja
auch demokratie und gefährdung der
demokratie weil demokratie sich gerade
verändert und wolfgang schäuble hat ja
auch gerade diese bürger räte
bürgerbeteiligung trete in den
vordergrund gebracht die menschen in
einer demokratie heute sind hier viel
aufgeklärter wir sind in der
wissensgesellschaft und wollen auch viel
mehr mitreden und gerade in diesem
format müssten wir viel viel mehr rein
demokratie verändert sich gerade und wir
müssen die leute viel mehr abholen sie
wollen viel mehr mitreden und das
angebot finde ich das sollte man den in
zukunft auch geben ja
wie sieht es bei euch aus
als würdest würdest du dir irgendeine
andere form von von demokratischer
beteiligung
also ich glaube generell ist es immer
schwierig weil andere einfluss an der
stelle ist dann ja nicht demokratisch
legitimiert aber ich halte es auf jeden
fall für notwendig gerade wenn wir auch
sehen dass viel mehr menschen wählen
dürfen als junge ich glaube phoenix
hatte er zuletzt sich auch einen
instagram post gezeigt und das könnte
man aber beispielsweise
dem könnte man entgegenwirken durch ein
wahlalter ab 16 als vorschlag oder
generell ist natürlich auch immer gut
wenn man sich in einer partei engagiert
ich glaube an meiner stelle ich habe da
sehr viel zu beigetragen in den letzten
paar wochen und bin da auch zufrieden
aber
es könnten auf jeden fall mehr leute
sich noch in parteien engagieren und in
einer globalisierten welt werden
natürlich auch beispielsweise andrews
immer wichtiger aber auch
großkonzerne da muss man dann halt aber
auch darauf achten
eben das was ich gerade angesprochen
habe inwiefern dieser einfluss nicht zu
sehr ja inwiefern dieser diese akteure
nicht zu großen einfluss haben werden
beispielsweise
vertreten von unternehmensinteressen ist
ja definitiv nicht demokratisch
legitimiert
ja wir sind gespannt auch heute auf das
auf das ergebnis und
ja wir haben höchstwahrscheinlich
darüber kann man jetzt gerade
spekulieren aber in einer koalition
landen oder die koalitionsmöglichkeiten
die jetzt aufgrund der umfragen aus den
letzten wochen möglich wären werden
alles koalitionen aus ja die aus 33
parteien besteht
vielleicht noch eine tour zur erklärung
worauf wir jetzt warten wir warten jetzt
auf die ersten zahlen der der der
prognose sind auch keine keine
hochrechnung die 18 uhr prognose die wir
gleich aus berlin gesehen werden kommt
zustande aufgrund von nachwahl erhebung
die wähler innen nach dem verlassen des
wahllokals
ja abgegeben haben also
informationen darüber wie sie wie sie
abgestimmt haben
deswegen genau werden wir haben noch
ungefähr fünf minuten bis es soweit ist
dann gehen wir zurück zu den kollegen
nach berlin und landen dann später noch
mal bei uns im live stream und werden
dann über mögliche
koalitionen auch weiter reden vielleicht
dennoch
interessant noch mal auf die auf die
eure tipps zu zu schauen ist sowieso bis
mir gerade im kopf geblieben mit deinen
das waren es 22
22 5% und vorher über über 30 wie
vielleicht noch mal die frage wie wie
kam dieser rasse optimismus vor drei
monaten zu standen ja also es vor drei
monaten hatten wir tatsächlich auch ein
ganz anderen stand das ist wirklich so
als anna lena berger kandidatin wurde
gab es ein riesen sprung nach oben für
die grünen und
also klar jetzt habe ich jetzt 22,5 auch
ja auch jetzt positiv im gegensatz zu
den umfragen die jetzt ergebnissen die
gerade kam
nichtsdestotrotz finde ich
es ist für die grünen riesenerfolg dass
dieses klima krisenthema komplett nach
nach vorne gedrängt worden und komplett
nach oben und ich würde sagen jetzt egal
wie das ergebnis jetzt erst mal ausgehen
wird das dass dieses thema jetzt
omnipräsent ist und überall da ist und
definitiv in der kommenden
legislaturperiode angegangen werden muss
ist schon ein riesenerfolg und
35 22 also da ja da gibt es geht erstmal
das thema wirklich bei allen jetzt
gesetzt ist ja und die grünen werden
mitregieren also auf jeden fall also für
mich ist ganz klar da führt kein weg
dran vorbei weil das thema klima einfach
da ist sehr viel optimismus hier
zumindest hinzu mal zu meiner rechten
hatte gerade gerade schon gesagt wir
werden jetzt gleich abgeben nach berlin
besser früher als zu spät um die 18 uhr
prognose mitnehmen zu können wir freuen
uns auch weiterhin über kommentare unter
unserem youtube live stream über weitere
fragen die vielleicht auch im laufe der
nächsten stunden nach der prognose noch
ja noch offen sind bei euch zu hause
oder unterwegs von wo auch immer er
zuschaut gerne auch fragen an unsere
bewohner in der wallstraße
ja und damit würde ich sagen
verabschieden wir uns jetzt gerade für
den moment und geben schon mal ab zu
unseren kollegin michaela kolster und
verdienten auch nach berlin
ja natürlich wäre es gibt zwei
neuralgische punkte für die csu droht
vielleicht unter 30 prozent zu rutschen
in bayern sie droht unter die fünf
prozent landesweit zu rutschen das ist
nicht der anspruch den csu hatte an sich
und das macht es auch für markus söder
durchaus gefährlich denn er ist bisher
nicht derjenige der der csu insgesamt
tolle wahlergebnisse geholt hat sofern
werden wir möglicherweise heute abend
auch ein stück schuldzuweisung zwischen
union oder zwischen cdu und csu sollte
man sagen sehen vielen dank soweit das
sind also nur noch wenige sekunden bis
18 uhr gleich werden wir ins zdf
wahlstudio
schalten um dort die prognose zu hören
natürlich wie bei phoenix immer liegen
sie bei uns auch die zahlen der ard die
werden wir dann im insight für sie
aufrufen so dass sie die zahlen von zdf
und ard haben und ich würde jetzt mal
sagen wir gehen darüber
jetzt die prognose für die
bundestagswahl
cdu/csu 24 prozent sehr deutliche
verluste schlechtestes ergebnis bisher
spd 26 prozent deutliche gewinne afd
zehn prozent verluste fdp 12 ähnlich wie
vor vier jahren linke 5 fast halbiert
grüne 14,5 deutliche gewinne andere
zusammen 8,5 jetzt hintereinander weg
zunächst die berlin die prognose der
forschungsgruppe wahlen sieht die spd
bei 23 prozent leichte gewinne cdu 17
prozent ähnlich wie 2016 grüne 22
prozent deutliche gewinne linke 14
prozent leichte verluste afd
6,5 mehr als halbiert fdp acht leichte
gewinne andere zusammen
9,5 und die prognose für das land
mecklenburg vorpommern die spd kommt auf
39 prozent sehr deutliche gewinne afg 17
prozent verluste cdu 14 verluste linke
zehn verluste grüne 6,5 leichte gewinne
und im landtag und die fdp mit 6 prozent
deutlichen gewinnen und wahrscheinlich
auch wieder
landtag die anderen zusammen 7,5 prozent
so das ist die grundlage für den
weiteren abend alle prognosen wir kehren
zum bus zurück was bedeutet die prognose
für die sitzverteilung für mögliche
koalitionen das alles jetzt ausführlich
von matthias fornoff ja und bettina
bevor wir auf die sitzverteilung gucken
und die möglichen konstellationen damit
wir keinen völligen zahlensalat hier
anrichten erst mal zur erinnerung noch
mal die prognose für die bundestagswahl
einen schritt zu weit standen und müssen
das noch mal zurück holen da ist sie die
prognose für den bundestag da sehen wir
die sehr großen verluste von union
deutliche zugewinne bei spd und grünen
und jetzt schauen wir mal auf die
sitzverteilung im neuen deutschen
bundestag und da sehen wir dass die
union auf 198 sitze käme die spd auf 215
afd 83 fdp 99 linke 41 und grüne 120 wir
haben es in der prognose aber gesehen
wir haben die linke bei genau fünf
prozent es kann also auch sein dass sie
nicht mit rein kommt deshalb haben wir
eine zweite grafik hier da hätten wir
dann 7 121 sitze insgesamt da käme die
cdu csu auf 200 spd 217 a steht 83 fdp
100 und grüne 121 das wie gesagt wenn
die linken an der fünf-prozent-hürde
scheitern würden und jetzt gucken wir
auf dem möglichen
regierungskonstellationen die sich
daraus ergeben hier ist die senkrechte
linie hinter der liegt die absolute
mehrheit die man braucht eine koalition
aus spd und union käme auf 413 sitze und
würde das schaffen spd und grüne union
und grüne jeweils nicht und jetzt sind
wir bei dreier bündnissen spd grüne und
fdp würden das deutlich schaffen 434
interessant spd grüne und linke also rot
grün rot würde es sogar dann nach
derzeitigem stand knapp verfehlen diese
absolute mehrheit wenn die linken denn
drin wären und zuletzt union grüne fdp
jamaika also 417 das würde auch reichen
dankeschön matthias so also die spd
führt in der prognose der
forschungsgruppe wahlen 26 zu 24 für die
union das ist nah beieinander und das
kann sich natürlich im laufe des abends
auch noch noch enger gestalten ja vielen
dank so weit die zahlen des zdf bei der
ard liegen die spd und die union sogar
gleichauf und wir gehen gleich mal zu
unserem kollegen erhard scherfer er hat
wie es die stimmung in der spd und wie
werden die zahlen dort aufgenommen
das ist ganz interessant michaela
kolster weil im moment ist es
vergleichsweise ruhig obwohl es im
atrium des willy-brandt-hauses
relativ voll geworden ist
zwischenzeitlich jetzt brandet jubel
hinter mir auf und ich kann ihnen
ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz genau sagen
worauf die menschen im atrium jetzt
reagieren es sind tatsächlich jetzt noch
viele mitglieder hier reingekommen und
auch an
der spd was sie jetzt gerade aktuell bei
jungen wie gesagt kann ich hier nicht
ganz genau sagen offenbar wird jetzt
über die großen monitore eine weitere
prognose vorgestellt vorhin gab es hier
nur die prognose des zdf und der name
der jubel dann sofort zu am lautesten
wurde als erste ergebnisse über sehen
bis jetzt auch noch mal bis der erste
prognosen kamen wir in mecklenburg
vorpommern da war es hier natürlich ganz
besonders laut und danach hat man
offensichtlich angefangen nachzudenken
und auch noch einmal abzuwarten aktuell
in diesen sekunden hat jetzt wieder
rhythmisches klatschen eingesetzt aber
das gilt ganz offensichtlich einem
interview dass hier geradezu gespielt
wird mit lars klingbeil auf der anderen
seite ist man hier wahrscheinlich und
nach wie vor gespannt darauf wie es sich
jetzt tatsächlich weiter entwickelt denn
diese zahlen die wir eben gesehen haben
die sind gerade an einem wahltag wie
heute und gerade mit den zahlen die sie
präsentiert worden sind ja noch nicht so
ganz aussagekräftig deswegen werden wir
uns wahrscheinlich das eine und andere
mal hier noch mal wieder melden müssen
michaela
damals tatsächlich noch wieder hören das
ist ja auch gut so und ich frage gleich
aber meinem kollegen gerd joachim von
fallois gehabt ein kopf an kopf rennen
so ist es nach wie vor wie sieht es bei
der union
ja wir stehen hier im wintergarten die
kameras deswegen haben wir nicht so viel
einsicht denen das eigentliche festzelt
aber ich glaube wir haben dort auch
bilder eingefangen es war hier sehr
ruhig als die prognose vorgelesen wurde
es gab noch einmal massiv applaus als
dann festgestellt wurde dass ein rot rot
grünes bündnis im moment zumindest nicht
funktionieren würde es ist sehr knapp
aber die cdu hat natürlich lange nicht
das ergebnis eingefahren mit dem man
hier heimlich gehofft hatte es geht ja
darum eigentlich die nase vor der spd zu
behalten das scheint vielleicht nicht
zuklappen nun liegt die letzte hoffnung
auf den briefwählern die traditionell
eigentlich er immer ein bisschen mehr zu
cdu csu und fdp tendieren das bleibt
abzuwarten jedenfalls kann das hier auch
noch ein langer abend werden die
hoffnung dass man doch noch an der
regierungsbeteiligung beteiligt wird die
hat man hier jedenfalls bei den zahlen
noch nicht aufgegeben und damit weiter
hat zustandes clark war den
bündnisgrünen
verdanken die kolumbianerin tempelhof da
war der jubel als das erste prognose kam
tatsächlich lauter als diese prognose
für die grünen das tatsächlich vermuten
lässt denn wenn die fotos ungefähr zehn
treffe ist bei um die 15 prozent
dann wäre das eigentlich schlechter als
fast alle umfragen die grünen zuletzt
gesehen hatten und wenn man in die
historie zurück schaut die letzten zwei
jahre lagen die grünen in umfragen
konstant über 20 prozent teilweise ja
sehr weit über 20 prozent also zuletzt
bei 14 15 prozent in umfragen zumindest
mitte 2018 also 15 dieser jubel der war
zwar sehr demonstrativ aber man hatte
sich natürlich völlig anderes erhofft
man hat eine grüne kanzler kandidaten
ins rennen geschickt mann hatte den
anspruch zum ersten mal vielleicht
überhaupt die tür zum kanzleramt auf
stoßen zu können und das sieht nach
dieser prognose überhaupt nicht so aus
ganz im gegenteil die fdp ist sogar
relativ nah an die grünen noch heran
gerutscht am lautesten übrigens war der
jubel hier in der columbiahalle als die
erste prognose für berlin kamen denn da
liegen nach den prognosen die grünen
sogar vor der spd und könnte womöglich
die regierende bürgermeisterin zu
stellen und natürlich war man dann hier
sehr euphorisch tatsächlich also wir
werden das ergebnis später einordnen
natürlich mit gästen hier am set wollen
jetzt aber erst mal weiterschauen so fdp
dort stehen katharina kühn
ja und die fdp die chance jetzt ziemlich
konzentriert auf das ergebnis als ist
dann kam für ihre partei gab es dann
auch applaus allerdings jubel würde ich
das nun nicht nennen aber dabei hat die
fdp das geschafft was sich in den
umfragen angedeutet hat es ist 12
prozent so sieht es momentan aus hat sie
erreicht ist damit auch wie jeanette
klag eben schon gesagt hat sehr nah an
die grünen herangekommen also man kann
sagen das konzept der fdp im wahlkampf
was sie verfolgt haben nämlich wirklich
auf eigene inhalte zu setzen sich nicht
an eine koalition zu schmieden das es
aufgegangen und man wird natürlich noch
sehen wie sich das ergebnis mit den
wählerstimmen aus der briefwahl
verändern wird da könnten sich ja auch
noch einige verschiebungen ergeben aber
was auf jeden fall schon mal deutlich
wird es könnte zu einem eben
historischen ergebnis kommt zweimal
hintereinander in einer bundestagswahl
zweistellig und damit zu alexander
keller bei der afg
bei der afg hat man deutlich positiv
reagiert auf das bundestagswahlergebnis
zehn beziehungsweise elf prozent das
hätte schlimmer kommen können ist
allerdings weniger im moment zumindest
diesmal der prognose als das
bundestagswahlergebnis
2017 jubel ist hier ausgebrannt einmal
als man das historisch schlechte
wahlergebnis der union auf bundesebene
bekannt gegeben hat und das
offensichtlich auch eine links koalition
aus spd grünen und der partei die linke
auf bundesebene nicht möglich ist
ansonsten hat man natürlich auch den
wahlerfolg in mecklenburg vorpommern
gefeiert zweitstärkste partei 18,5
prozent in der prognose dass es mehr als
man dort erwarten konnte also bei der
afg im moment alles etwas eben durch
wachsenden bereich und diese 10 11
prozent auf bundesebene die liga
eigentlich genau in dem korridor wo man
jetzt über
interpretation und überbewertungen was
kann das für die partei für die
verschiedenen parteiflügeln bedeuten
durchaus steigen kann also so hat das
wahlergebnis vielleicht noch keine
klärung gebracht das ist allerdings die
prognose wie es tatsächlich ausgeht
reden wir sind damit zu katja fuchs zu
den linken
genau hier ist die stimmung sehr
schlecht gewesen es gab ein lautes als
die fünf prozent verkündet worden sind
und viele entsetzte gesichter weil damit
hatte man nicht gerechnet man hatte doch
gedacht dass man weiter von der 5
prozent hürde entfernt ist zweistellig
das war eigentlich mal der wunsch jörg
schindler hat dann auf der bühne auch
noch mal gesagt es liegt nicht an uns
wir haben zusammengestanden haben einen
tollen wahlkampf gemacht aber scheinbar
ein wahlkampf der nicht die wählerinnen
und wähler angesprochen hat und es wird
ein langer abend werden hier bei der
linken denn es stellt sich die frage
bleibt es bei den fünf prozent wird es
vielleicht sogar noch weniger werden
dann wäre die frage nach direktmandaten
die einzige möglichkeit noch in den
bundestag zu kommen auch die
koalitionsfrage über die ja in den
vergangenen wochen immer wieder geredet
wurde rot rot grün das sieht im moment
nicht danach aus das heißt es bleibt
weiterhin sehr spannend und sehr
ernüchternd die bühne hinter mir ist
schon wieder leer die meisten leute sind
auch draußen gerade und muss glaube ich
über dieses ergebnis erst mal
miteinander sprechen und damit gebe ich
absolut csu und hans werner fittkau
vielen dank katharina köhler auch bei
der csu hat sich der saal hier schon ein
bisschen gelehrt holen was man voller
hier als die ersten zahlen gaben jetzt
sind einige csu-anhänger die hier in der
parteizentrale anwesend sind
rausgegangen draußen ist es etwas besser
in sachen corona ja zu händeln ist ein
schöner warmer abend in münchen hier
drinnen wurde ist wollen erstmal still
als die erste prognose zahlen hier kamen
gerade von der ard 24 5 24 5 beide große
parteien und es wurde dann richtig laut
als die zahlen für bayern kam die csu
legt nämlich laut prognose des
bayerischen rundfunk bei 33 prozent das
würde sehr wahrscheinlich reichen um aus
eigener kraft die fünf prozent also mit
den mit der kraft der zweitstimmen die
fünf prozent hürde zu überwinden und in
den bundestag einzuziehen man wäre dann
nicht auf die direktmandate angewiesen
denn das war so ein worst case das war
so eine horrorvorstellung hier die csu
in bayern dass man aus eigener kraft
nicht in den bundestag kommt und wie
gesagt eben nur über die direktmandate
fast die führung zu diesem ergebnis zu
sagen hat es wenn wir dann im laufe des
abends hören markus söder ich vermute
dass er die parole ausgibt die csu hat
in bayern trotz dieses kandidaten der
cdu des kanzlerkandidaten armen armin
laschet der sehr unbeliebt war und ist
in bayern trotzdem ist es der csu
gelungen auf 33 prozent zu kommen das
sind zwar immer noch rund fünf prozent
weniger als bei der letzten
bundestagswahl in bayern aber ich
vermute eben dann wird die devise
ausgeben wir sind dadurch mit einem
blauen auge davon gekommen das werden
wir im laufe des abends hören und ich
gebe für den moment zurück nach berlin
vielen dank an hans werner fittkau noch
an alle korrespondenten vieler
stimmungsbild aus den parteizentralen
der professor fest
wer jetzt vor allem die zahlen von ard
und zdf nehmen dann sind wir ja
eigentlich fast genauso schlau wie
vorher vor 18 uhr aber die richtung geht
das kann man ehrlicherweise stand jetzt
nicht sagen wenn wir auf den boden
schauen wenn wir auch auf die beiden
landtagswahlen schauen die prognosen die
davor liegen unterscheiden sich
bemerkenswert doch an vielen stellen
zwei punkte zwischen den instituten
teilweise sogar noch mehr das deute
darauf hin dass es auch für die
demoskopen schwieriger wahlabend ist und
das wiederum heißt es kann ein langer
wahlabend werden also da kann doch eine
menge bewegung in die zahlen kommen muss
sogar denn am ende muss ja ein ergebnis
da stehen das sind heute wirklich 18 uhr
zahlen die wir noch mit ein bisschen
mehr vorsicht hat sonst vielleicht
genießen müssen der generalsekretärin
der spd lars klingbeil hat er schon mal
die regierung sich die
regierungsfähigkeit
betont und hat gesagt wir haben auch den
regierungsauftrag ist das nicht ein
bisschen früh
erstmal ist es ja ein schillerndes
konstrukt dieser regierungsauftrag das
kann ja immer alle parteien sehr sehr
gut wähler aufträge regierungsaufträge
als solchen wahlergebnis nur auszulesen
formal ist es erstmal ganz offener punkt
am ende braucht eine kanzlerinnen kann
zwar eine mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag klar lars klingbeil wird sich
eher auf die zahlen aus dem zdf berufen
haben zwei prozentpunkte wäre schon ein
abstand mit dem man argumentieren kann
es gab ja auch signale aus der csu im
vorfeld dass man aus dieser position
heraus nicht den kanzleranspruch wird
aufrechterhalten können aber trotzdem
wenn man ehrlich ist es dafür eigentlich
heute aber noch viel zu früh und formal
gibt es einen solchen regierungsanspruch
oder auftrag nicht so fern stehen uns
das kann man glaube ich heute jetzt eine
der wenigen sachen die man schon sagen
kann das wird auch nach diesem wahlabend
spannend wie es weitergeht schauen wir
einmal auf die zahlen die die ard hat in
ihrer prognose da kommen wir haben es ja
schon gesagt cdu und spd gleichauf 25
afg und fdp auf elf prozent linke 5 auch
da knapp die grünen bei 15 also bei den
kleineren unterscheidet sich nicht so
deutlich aber bei den beiden größeren
cdu csu und spd ist es eben ein kopf an
kopf rennen um nochmal darauf einzugehen
regierungsanspruch ja oder nein
letztendlich ist es ja so dass die
koalition entscheidet es muss auch nicht
unbedingt die größte fraktion
nun die fraktion sein die den kanzler
stellt nein keineswegs diese regel kennt
das grundgesetz nicht schon es gibt ja
auch historische beispiele genau dafür
dass nicht die stärkste fraktion den
kanzler gestellt hat könnte auch an 2011
in baden württemberg denken den der
beginn der ära kretschmann würden manche
sagen da hatte er 25 prozent die cdu
hatte damals in baden württemberg 37
prozent und trotzdem völlig klar dass
die union die cdu in baden württemberg
abgewählt war jetzt geht es darum
mehrheiten zu finden stabile mehrheiten
zu finden das ist vielleicht schon ein
signal dass man aus diesen ersten
prognosen herauslesen kann selbst wenn
es für rot grün rot reicht dann wäre das
eine wirklich sehr sehr sehr knappe
mehrheit ich glaube nicht dass olaf
scholz sich darauf einlassen würde also
insofern für rot rot grün ist das glaube
ich das würde ich jetzt schon fast mutig
sagen doch ein schwieriger also hat die
kampagne der cdu an der stelle gegriffen
und wir sind wieder zurück in unserem
youtube live stream aus essen gerade
haben wir die ersten zahlen der prognose
gesehen zur bundestagswahl aus
berlin von unseren kollegen dort und
kollegin
wir stehen hier auf der zeche zollverein
immer noch möchten jetzt gleich darüber
sprechen ja was
das was jetzt die reaktionen auch von
den unseren bewohnerinnen der
phönixstraße so sind matthias genau aber
vorher seid ihr natürlich auch da
draußen schon gefragt sagte uns seid ihr
zufrieden mit dieser ersten prognose
seid ihr nicht so zufrieden könnte es
besser sein schreibt es mal in den chat
reihen nimmt dann unseren umfragen teil
die wir immer wieder machen sagt uns
eure meinung aber ganz ehrlich mich
interessieren hier so runde so einige
meinungen jetzt gerade denn die zeit
sind ja doch anders als sich das manche
erhofft haben von daher lasse ich das
feld wieder
danke matthias wir freuen uns dann
gleich auf die kommentare und auf genau
erste stimmung aus dem netz jetzt möchte
ich aber hier fragen direkt zu meiner
rechten ist die grünen du hattest 22,5
prozent heute getippt die aktuellen
ersten prognosen sagen so um die 15
prozent
sprechen den grünen um die 15 prozent zu
was was ist jetzt eine reaktion auf
dieses ergebnis ja es ist natürlich
nicht das erwartete ergebnis und ich
hatte da ja auch gesagt dass ich da sehr
extrem optimistisch bin
die grünen
ist für mich wichtig dass sie
mitregieren und mit in die regierung
kommen und das können sie mit 15 prozent
sehr wohl und von daher müssen wir
einfach gucken wie das jetzt noch
weitergeht das sind erste prognose
spd und union scheint gerade ja gleich
auf zu sein die ersten zahlen haben uns
beiden so um die um die 25 prozent
gelegen
sein befinden aktuell also mir
persönlich geht es im moment gut ich
kann mit dem ergebnis
mit dem ergebnis für die spd gut leben
wundert mich trotzdem dass die cdu dann
doch noch so knapp dran gekommen ist und
die grünen dann doch so wenig punkte
zumindest laut prognose gekriegt haben
sich die grünen definitiv stärker
erwartet auch in der wählergunst ganz
klar ja die linke muss glaube ich noch
ein bisschen zittern aber ansonsten ist
es jetzt nicht so überraschend also da
wurden zumindest die prognosen oder so
wiedergegeben wie die
prognosen in den letzten wochen auch
waren dann möchte ich mal direkt
übergehen zu alles sah die cdu hatte ich
gerade gesagt liegt mit der spd gerade
gleichauf was die ersten zahlen angeht
natürlich kann sich da im laufe des
abends noch noch noch was verändern
was ist das jetzt für ein gefühl für
dich 25 prozent cdu wohl jedoch die
letzten wochen relativ weit unten lagen
ich hatte heute ich hab schon gesagt das
ist ja gerade ein bisschen bergauf geht
für den für die cdu beziehungsweise
jetzt auch für den abschnitt
ja mal schauen
25 prozent spd 25 prozent cdu
abwarten
ist das gut über koalition wollen wir
wollen wir wollen wir später noch
sprechen
was besser ist das für dich jetzt schon
ja der regierungsauftrag für für armin
armin laschet oder was was versprichst
du dir jetzt aus diesen guten ergebnis
für die cdu ich verspreche mir daraus
darfst du vielleicht noch ein zwei
prozent
bekommen und die spd natürlich unter uns
gehen wird
wir haben jetzt die fdp war zwölf
prozent lägen
man muss dazu sagen fdp war bei der
letzten
bundestagswahl 2017 ist ja als
drittstärkste fraktion jetzt dann auch
in den bundestag eingezogen ähnlich
jetzt bei 10 prozent die fdp bei 12
prozent
wie ist also wahr was was ist deine
reaktion ganz auf dass das wahlergebnis
ja ich hatte ja gerade schon gesagt ich
würde mir wünschen dass die ersten vier
plätze also a dass wir möglichst waren
die grünen rankommen wenn wir bei 12
bleiben und die grünen bei 15 ist das
glaube ich für die fw für die fdp schon
ein riesenschritt ich hoffe aber auch
ehrlicherweise dass die absehen noch
unter zehn prozent kommt weil ich noch
mal mit einem zweistelligen ergebnis
ehrlicherweise nicht leben könnte vor
allem so nah an der fdp daran und für
die fdp ist das natürlich historisch
zwei mal zweistellig
und ich hoffe das bleibt so vielleicht
ganz noch 13% ich glaube es nicht ich
glaube 11 12 ist ein ganz guter tipp
also ich bin damit relativ zufrieden vor
allem fdp die ja doch eine zeitlang aus
dem bundestag draußen war
zwölf prozent die
kfd hatte ich gerade wird es schon
angesprochen da möchte ich aber jetzt
natürlich die fdp hat andreas noch mal
einbeziehen
knapp unter den zahlen für die für die
fdp oder ungefähr also je nachdem wo
nach mann mann mann gp forschungsgruppe
wahlen zdf zahlen oder infratest dimap
ungefähr gleichauf mit der mit der fdp
was was sagst du zu elf und zehn prozent
erwartet genau wie erwartet und den
vergleich mit den anderen parteien der
ist für uns unsinnig sind
oppositionspartei klar ist bisher 13
statt 10 prozent gar keine frage tut der
qualität des der opposition aber keinen
großen abbruch hin so viel für mich
keine überraschung und der vergleich mit
den anderen parteien in brauche ich
nicht
es ist ja auf jeden fall also
drittstärkste fraktion hat jetzt gerade
gerade schon gesagt sie die letzten
jahre über
wi-fi wird zudem wünschen sollte sich
die fdp in der opposition
und genauso wie jetzt viele wunde und
loslegen gar keine frage dass das
wichtig eine opposition ist wichtig eine
große opposition ist auch wichtig und
das wird ja noch sehr interessant wer im
lauf des abends wer sich jetzt wirklich
auch eine regierung wiederfinden und
auch in der opposition wiederfinden
möglicherweise diese oppositionsführer
rolle dann auch entsprechend ausführt
naja das ist für mich sehr wichtig dass
oppositionell aus dem westen die kern
des wortes ist dass es auch gelebt wird
und dass man nicht immer ein
einheitsbrei bat das würde ich mir
wünschen bei den parteien die jetzt
nicht an die regierung kommen das gab
sagt oppositionsführer rolle da möchten
wir aber trotzdem auch noch mal möchte
ich mal kurz darauf eigene noch auf den
regierungsauftrag was ich gerade schon
mal alles angesprochen hatte
wie siehst du jetzt olaf scholz
automatisch auf grund der der doch wie
zu erwarten
ganz guten zahlen in der lage bzw
denkst du oder scholz sollte die nächste
bundesregierung anführen und wenn ja in
also oder sich gegen die übungen gegen
armin laschet da jetzt auch behaupten
wenn es so bleibt also ich glaube
klassisch sollte es so sein dass
derjenige der die meisten stimmen
bekommt oder die partei die die meisten
stimmen bekommt halt den
regierungsauftrag bekommt und versucht
halt koalitionen zu bilden wenn es dann
die spd am ende ist dann ist es ganz
klar auch olaf scholz gestern in der
hand hat wenn es armin laschet ist hätte
er halt dann auch in dem fall den
regierungsauftrag jetzt aber vielleicht
heute abend schon darüber zu sprechen ja
auch wenn wir weniger stimmen haben
trotzdem vielleicht eine regierung zu
stellen halte ich definitiv zu früh also
da sollte man dann vielleicht darüber
sprechen wenn halt derjenige der den
auftrag bekommen hat keine koalition
zusammenbekommen wir sammeln auch erste
reaktion jetzt hatte lars klingbeil spd
generalsekretär kurz nach der verkündung
der ersten prognosen auch gesagt dass er
damit dass die spd gerade vorne liegt
den klaren auftrag zur regierungsbildung
sieht und
ja natürlich will dass olaf scholz
kanzler wird es schlimm wenn herr klink
mal was anderes gesagt hätte irgendwo
die spd hat sie auch in den letzten
jahren arg gebeutelt also die haben
schon lange keine wahl mehr gewonnen
glaube ich schon gar nicht auf
bundesebene und dass man da vielleicht
auch ein bisschen zu euphorisch gerade
in dem interview geht
kann man ihm da glaube ich nicht allzu
übel nehmen aber ich würde erstmal
abwarten bis das die zweite dritte
hochrechnung kommt und dann schauen wir
mal weiter
vielleicht haben wir jetzt auch schon
beziehungsweise wir wollen erstmal noch
über reaktionen sprechen bevor wir auf
die auf die auf die tipps dann gehen
hier
vorliegen michael keiner
bundesgeschäftsführer der grünen der im
zdf sagt ist fällt ihm schwer sich zu
freuen bei den zahlen die jetzt aktuell
vorliegen und er möchte in ruhe nach dem
ergebnis überlegen wo welche also was
was daraus daraus folgt wie gesagt über
koalition möglich
koalitionsmöglichkeiten sprechen wir
noch
was ist denn deinen danken für style
oder was würdest du dir jetzt wünschen
was die was die grünen daraus ziehen das
ergebnis ja das ist eine sehr gute frage
also
zufrieden sein kann man natürlich nicht
und erwartet nun man sieht es ja auch an
meinen zahlen die dich auch schon mehr
natürlich nicht die 22 aber schon eine
höhere zahl ist es jetzt die
drittstärkste kraft und
wo ich oder was ich bei michael keller
da verstehe ist
hinter hinter diesen grünen programm
steckt ja auch natürlich stecken themen
und diese themen möchte man ja auch
voranbringen und
ist es in den konstellationen die sich
vielleicht ergeben könnten ist es dann
noch möglich die themen die man als
partei hat da zu setzen und da verstehe
ich schon dass das erst mal der
rückblick kommt zu sagen mensch wir
müssen uns erst mal selber kritisch
damit auseinandersetzen ja das heißt
weiter gucken wie der abend weiter läuft
wie zahlen weiter sich entwickeln hat
sich die partei mit ihren themen nicht
durchsetzen können kann man das jetzt
schon sagen vielleicht auch werden schon
vor der 18 uhr prognose über das thema
klima gesprochen dass auch alle anderen
verteilen sich auf das thema gestürzt
haben jetzt im vorfeld ist das ja kam
kann man kann man eine vermutung
aufstellen das ist dass es eventuell
auch daran gelegen haben könnte
das ist nicht sehr sehr gute frage haben
die leute jetzt die grünen nicht gewählt
weil sie das thema klima so stark
besetzen oder haben sie die grünen nicht
gewählt weil sie finden dass alle
anderen parteien das thema klima jetzt
sowieso besetzen also das wäre eine ganz
interessante frage die die ich finde
warum
mir ist gerade bei dem klima thema warum
wundert die grünen jetzt nicht gewählt
also entweder spielt keine rolle für die
leute oder sie denken ach mensch die
kunst genauso gut das wird sich dann
zeigen in der zukunft
einmal noch kurz kurz anschließend die
zahl für die partei die linke wollen wir
nicht vorenthalten liegt aktuell bei 5
prozent in den ersten prognosen
also würde so ganz knapp in den
bundestag
einziehen wie gesagt und den zahlen kann
sich auch im laufe des abends wird sich
noch was ändern sagen wir so es wird
gerne noch mal übergeben zu meinem
kollegen matthias der für uns online
beobachtet was da so abgeht
matthias welche beobachtungen welche
kommentare welche das was kraft kommt
aus dem netz bei der ein jahres auf
jeden fall super spannend ist es
natürlich die frage an unsere community
gewesen wie zufrieden seid ihr
eigentlich mit der prognose finde ich
toll so finde ich nicht so doll sagen 46
prozent geht so sagen 35 prozent und
finde ich top sagen 17 prozent das heißt
der großteil unserer community im netz
ist nicht ganz zufrieden mit diesen
ersten prognosen liegt jetzt bis jetzt
hier liegen haben was kann ich ansonsten
spannendes sagen die wahlbeteiligung
nach aktuellen zahlen könnte wohl etwas
niedriger sein als 2017 und was für mich
ein sehr sehr spannende zahl war die
gerade über den ticker ging laut hde an
alyse hat die union fast 1,4 millionen
wähler an die spd verloren das ist ja
schon eine ganz schön gehörige zahl und
vielleicht werfe ich diese zahl mal
direkt darüber zu dir alles was glaubst
du woran hat es gelegen dass die union
dann ja doch das ist ja eine ganz schöne
masse an menschen gerade an die spd
verloren hat ja über eine milliarde
menschen verloren
millionen land millionen
millionen ist schon viel wieso weshalb
warum kann ich nicht sagen
das ist eine gute frage kann ich nicht
beantworten weil ich wie die cdu sie
meist die übereinstimmung und ich frage
mich warum die nicht die cdu wählen also
bei dir hast also keine idee woran es
liegen könnte
alyssa kann sich elegant 100 tage hat
sie für die union auf jeden fall auch
gestanden als fehlende spannend ist dann
auch ein blick auf die gewinne und
verluste nach den aktuellen prognosen da
ist tatsächlich die union mit acht
prozent weniger deutlicher verlierer
wohingegen die grünen die jetzt bei
vielen vielleicht negativ da stehen weil
sie nicht die traumergebnisse holt haben
6,1 prozent mehr geholt haben als noch
2000 17 und tatsächlich das beste
ergebnis ihrer
von allen wahlen die sie bundesweit bei
denen sie bundesweit eingetreten sind
geholt haben das haben sich auch immer
mehr menschen geäußert
von der afg der spitzenkandidat gruppe a
der sagt ganz klar das sind verluste die
man verschmerzen muss es ist dennoch ein
solides ergebnis der fdp
generalsekretär volker wissing sagt
gegenüber dem zdf die wählerinnen und
wähler wollen uns auf jeden fall stark
und die parteivorsitzende linken susanne
hennig welt so ist natürlich enttäuscht
vom wahlergebnis das sagt sie in zdf und
das ist denke ich eines der spannenden
dingen heute denn die linken die tänzelt
ja gerade in den prognosen um die fünf
prozent
von daher wird das auf jeden fall noch
ein ganz spannendes thema über den abend
verteilt sein
und ja dann würde ich sagen fangen wir
vielleicht
schauen wir jetzt einmal noch mal auf
unsere kleine flipchart hier
und gucken da noch mal rüber dafür muss
ich einmal meinen laptop drehen dann
können wir das man mit den ersten
prognosen vergleich nicht nehmen jetzt
weil die vom zdf da werden wir hier bei
der union bei 24 haben aber auch
teilweise 25 in der ard beim zdf sind
wir bei 26 26
25 da ich würde sagen ihr zwei liegt auf
jeden fall nahm mit euren tipp dann bei
der afg sind wir
13 11 andreas wo ich sagen auch ganz gut
getippt die fdp das würde ich sogar
sagen ist ja fast
auf den schlag 11 12 bei ard und zdf
beide zahlen hat so genannte sehr gut
getippt die linken da hatte isa wohl
schon ein bisschen in die zukunft
geguckt mit sechs ist bei beiden derzeit
bei 5 beide zu gerechtigkeit hin und die
grünen liegen bei
14,5 und
15 also ein relativ großer unterschied
leider zu dem tipp den du gesagt hast ja
und was ergibt das für die
koalitionsmöglichkeiten
und tan dun ist möglich eine große
koalition derzeit ist aber auch möglich
eine ampelkoalition aus spd grünen und
fdp und eine jamaika-koalition aus der
union grünen und fdp naja und nicht
verschlagen jetzt seid ihr dran ihr
müsst uns verraten welche koalition den
euro wunschkoalition ist und weil es ja
langweilig wäre das einfach nur zu sagen
sondern wie das auch mal bildlich sehen
wollen habe ich hier ein paar kleine
lego steinen aus meinem kinderzimmer
mitgebracht ich leg sie mal hierhin ihr
könnt euch ja mal rum geben und dann
sind wir gespannt welche koalition ihr
so favorisiert
greift zu
eine breite palette an farben gerne rum
geben oder
vorbei
[Musik]
gehen wir das mal weiterschauen
auf die finger
der vorstellung
dann biss noch am aufbauen ja
du hast so ich erzähle ich selber hast
vier steine in mir ich habe die linke
noch so als wir im pinken aber man muss
ja gucken wie die mehrheitsverhältnisse
sich dann ergeben werden und deswegen
sagte ich fehlt mir da noch die fantasie
und deswegen habe ich jetzt diese drei
steinchen her da ist würdig die ampel
jetzt im fokus muss man auch sagen jetzt
auch in den in den umfragen die es so
die letzten wochen neuer vor der wahl
gegeben hat hat die ampelkoalition aus
spd grünen und fdp in den umfragen am
besten abgeschnitten die meiste zeit
du hast dich jetzt auch das dafür
entschieden
warum die auch
gut also die spd ist jetzt die stadt
prognosen die erst mal die stärkste
kraft und
wir haben thema klima und wirtschaft
wobei ich auch sagen würde hier die
grünen sind was was wirtschaft angeht
auch mittlerweile ziemlich stark
vielfalt meinungsvielfalt und
der vielfalt an den themen und das
gemeinsam zu diskutieren und umzusetzen
stelle ich mir schon ganz ganz gut vor
jetzt hat annalena baerbock und die
grüne vorfeld auch mal gesagt wenn dann
mit spd mit wäre wenn dann also wir
wollen auf jeden fall den klaren
regierungsauftrag bekommen wir wollen
die kanzlerin stellen auch letzte woche
noch an den letzten diskussionen die man
wie man so zugehört hat
trotzdem hauptsache teil der
einer einer regierungskoalition
da sind wir wieder beim ich kenne also
natürlich kommt es darauf an wie die
grünen ihre themen
einbringen können und wie sie da also
bei koalitionsverhandlungen wird man
jetzt das ja sehen und und wie die
themen da auch angenommen werden von den
koalitionspartnern also
ich finde also gerade beim thema klima
kann man jetzt nicht sagen wir machen da
jetzt die die großen kompromisse da muss
es schon bei gewissen themen wirklich
eine klare linie geben klimaneutralität
bis 2050 und 20 35 tschuldigung und
und da verstehe ich michael kellner der
dann sagt wir müssen uns dann sortieren
ich habe mir noch selten vorlieben von
katrin göring eckardt die heute haben in
der ard noch gesagt hatte ja wir werden
dafür sorgen dass wir klimaschutz und
gerechtigkeit mit einem aufbruch
verbindende und sagte auch hat er
nochmal darauf bezug genommen dass viele
junge menschen auch darauf hoffen dass
die hundertprozentige energie da
reingesteckt wird möchte mal direkt
übergeben zu unserer jungen erstwählerin
lissa bei dir ja
mein wunsch war eigentlich dass wir noch
irgendwie auch wenn es unrealistisch war
die drittstärkste kraft werden wer für
60 league verhältnisse sehr also es war
sehr unrealistisch und ist es jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch nicht geworden
ich glaube aber dass eine ampel
koalition fällt die spd jetzt vorne
liegt aber auch so weil wir schon mal
beim einkaufsverhandlungen ausgetreten
sind einfach strategisch kämmerer wäre
ich glaube hätten wir jetzt nochmal
jamaika verhandlungen wäre es sehr
schwierig für christian hinter noch mal
zurück zu ziehen und las bin finde ich
auch sehr spannend was er gesagt hat
weil vor vier jahren wurde die fdp ja
wirklich
also
dafür gehasst dass sie nicht in eine
regierung
gegangen ist wo ihre themen nicht
vertreten waren weil sehr viele
eigentlich nur grünen themen und sehr
viele schwarze themen übernommen wurden
außerdem glaube ich auch dass wir mit
einer ampel den größten
gesellschaftlichen fortschritt erreichen
weil die cdu viele gesellschaftliche
themen blockiert beispielsweise
wahlrecht ab 16 legalisierung von
cannabis
219 abschaffen leihmutterschaft aktive
sterbehilfe
das sind halt alles sachen über die
nicht so prominent im wahlkampf geredet
werden aber es sind natürlich sachen die
sehr wichtig sind wenn man über die
frage in was für einer gesellschaft wir
leben wollen würde ich also der linde
hatte im vorfeld auch häufig betont das
ist halt mit der mit der fdp keine
verschiebung nach links geben geben
werde jetzt ja spd und grüne ist das für
dich ist es dann noch die alternativen
ich glaube dass das also sehr viele
leute halten eine ampel für sehr
unrealistisch weil sie meinen mann kommt
nicht auf einen nenner
ich habe also ich glaube in sachen klima
weil spd und grüne sich da auch sehr
nahe sind wird die fdp in sachen ein
paar sachen oder in ein paar stellen
einbüßen müssen
aber man kann beispielsweise
arbeitsmarkt und sozialpolitik könnte
man sagen man geht als fdp den
mindestlohn von zwölf euro mit aber
dafür machen wir eine gesetzliche aktien
rente das sind halt alles super
spannende kompromisse wo man auch sehr
viele inhalte übernehmen kann so oder so
herr lindner setzt er auch auf
finanzministerium von der schau mal was
da
geht alles du hast nur zwei steine vor
vor dir liegen
schwarz-rot sich also für dich wer ist
ein
weiter so ein weiter so ich glaube das
hat ein bisschen breiter zu tun da habe
ich ich glaube zu sehr angst vor zu viel
veränderung
der schwarze steines oben weil ich
natürlich hoffe mit der führung von wie
alt bist du vielleicht noch einmal
nachschauen aber ich glaube die spd
möchte ja nicht so gerne
schwarze steinchen um steinchen oben
sehe ich bei dir andreas sind ich nach
rechts
habt habt ihr doch mehr übereinstimmung
ich habe das ganze jetzt noch mal
überlegt und auch die aussage von der
fdp und ich ziehe jetzt diese sache
zurück ich mache überhaupt keinen
vorschlag ich würde ganz gerne haben
dass die kriegen wir auseinander jetzt
klare anzeichen zeigen
ich würde ganz gerne haben dass die cdu
sich in der opposition regeneriert und
wieder mehr konservativ wird das würde
dafür sprechen was er jetzt gesagt aber
die finde ich auch nicht gut die ampel
also insofern habe ich jetzt keine
meinung dazu ja kann ich finde nichts
gut davon
dazu werde ich den dreier kombination
wird sehr schwer das erste mal es wird
sehr schwer sich abzustimmen und wenn
ich im grunde ist gerade auch schon
gesagt hat große geschacher geht los wer
setzt seine position kompromiss wirft
immer schatten den thoma zitat ist auch
ganz klar man wird eben aufeinander
zugehen müssen und das hat eben am ende
des tages zur folge dass sich keiner
richtig durchsetzen können und sich in
dem gesamt verabschiedeten programm sich
keiner richtig wiederfindet
ist so gewählt man muss jetzt auch bei
den beiden da dazu sagen dass ja wer
jetzt auch den kanzler
wir stellen wird dass eine mehrzahl der
der der wähler innen hier im land ja
auch nicht sich für einen eine person
entscheiden konnten beziehungsweise die
die person die als stärkste kraft raus
geht die partei die als stärkste kraft
raus geht wird mich die mehrheit der
bevölkerung hinter sich haben
biondi hatten wir jetzt noch nicht und
ich schiele rüber und es ist es ist es
ist sind es ist unklar es ist unklar
bitte
also rot und grün sind für mich gesetzt
in der koalition und dann kommt halt
wirklich drauf anja mit mit wem man die
besten
also mit wem man am besten seinen
interessen umsetzen kann ob es dann die
fdp oder die linken in dem fall sind
wenn die linke in den bundestag
reinkommen dafür hat olaf scholz ja ganz
klar gesagt müssen die linken ein paar
punkte in ihrem parteiprogramm
vielleicht überarbeiten und aber wenn
das der fall wäre und glaube ich schon
dass es rot grün rot geben könnte also
du hast du siehst die die möglichkeit
einer koalition mit den mit den linken
einzugehen wo ich meine die über die
bereitschaft von von seiten der linken
war
[Musik]
geteilt oder
hat also darauf an wir wissen wen man
gefragt hat kommt nachher auf die
koalitionsverhandlungen also da ist dann
olaf scholz als verhandlungsführer und
die spd-spitze dann wahrscheinlich
gefragt mit wem man halt am besten
das land regieren kann in den nächsten
vier jahren und ob es dann die fdp ist
oder die linken das wird dann ja der
herbst und winterzeit
ja es bleibt offen verlor noch spannend
die
koalitionsverhandlungen also es wird
jetzt erst mal erst mal viel gesprochen
die die nächsten wochen den nächsten
tagen viel diskutiert auch unter den
parteien also sind wir gespannt was was
dabei
rauskommt
vielleicht noch mal einen einblick ins
ins netz ein blick
auf unsere
online community wollen wir natürlich
auch weiter einbinden genau so ist das
und da gibt es auf jeden fall spannende
ergebnisse entschuldigt wenn ich
manchmal ein bisschen runter gucke dann
muss ich gerade die aktuellen ergebnisse
mir auch anschauen wir haben euch
gefragt welche koalition wünscht ihr
euch und tatsächlich sind da sehr viele
liszts meinung die ampel liegt sehr weit
vorne mit 51 prozent danach kommt eine
deutschland koalition die allerdings
auch schon innerhalb der großen
koalition genug stimmen nach derzeitigen
prognosen hätte danach jamaika und ganz
hinten dann eine kenia koalition und ich
finde eine einschätzung von buches ganz
spannend bus sagt fdp mit jamaika da
geht die partei als kleiner partner dann
vielleicht unter die fdp dagegen in der
ampel mit den linken koalitionspartnern
da könnte man ein deutlicheres profil
sich holen besser würdest du das genauso
sehen ist das vielleicht die chance der
fdp in einer ampel nämlich sich klarer
zu positionieren innerhalb einer
regierung und nicht ein großes ganzes zu
werden generell also sehe ich das auch
sehr ähnlich deswegen habe ich mich ja
für eine ampel entschieden ich glaube
bei einer jamaika wäre die gefahr
obwohl wir uns inhaltlich gerade den
gesellschaftspolitischen themen sehr von
der union und entscheiden dass man
beispielsweise erfolge der union oder
erfolge der fcp häufig sehr union zu
rechnen würde das wäre bei einer ampel
nicht der fall zumal wir auch die ganz
klare voraussetzung haben keine
aufweichung der schuldenbremse keine
steuererhöhungen und dabei bleibt die
partei und ich glaube dass die fdp auch
nicht in eine regierung
ohne diese voraussetzung einzuhalten
also wäre das auf jeden fall ein sehr
großer erfolg zumal an dieser koalition
ja auch sehr besonders ist dass wir
quasi
drei parteien haben die zumindest
oberflächlich für drei verschiedene
bereiche stehen soziales umwelt und
wirtschaft und ich glaube es wäre auf
jeden fall ein sehr großer erfolg für
die jeweiligen parteien wenn sie ihre
kernthemen sah durch kriegen würden ja
wenn wir danke und wenn wir beim thema
koalition ist dann ist eine frage die
heinz schreibt die möchte ich mal
aufnehmen die ist ein bisschen
kritischer und vielleicht gebe ich die
mal einmal an den bieren hier vorne der
hain schreibt nämlich ich finde es
schade für einen rechtsstaat dass man
eine partei welche vielleicht über zehn
prozent der stimmen holt nämlich die fdp
von vornherein komplett ausschließt ist
das nicht vorbei am wählerwillen fehler
in will
finde ich nicht dass es am wähler
wunsch vorbei ist weil man sich halt
vorher im wahlkampf ja schon ganz klar
positioniert hat und von vornherein
gesagt hat mit der afg gehen wir keine
koalition ein und dann darf man sich
auch nachher nicht beschweren wenn ja
wenn dann immer noch gesagt wird dass
man keine koalition mit der fdp eingehen
zumal glaube ich auch die afg immer
gesagt hat sie möchte eigentlich mit gar
keinem so wirklich ein schatten die
diskussion entschuldigung eine staaten
diskussion haben wir von vornherein
gesagt habe wir werden für besitz
koalieren wenn wir 25 prozent oder
ähnliches kommen würden alle anderen
fragen sind utopische würden auch wenn
es gehen würde nicht als juniorpartner
mit der cdu in einer gemeinsame
regierung geben die aussage weil man
ganz klar so wird es erst in den user
das schreibt richtig ausgrenzung ist ja
auch ich muss ein bisschen zu spüren
sagt ja auch nur alle demokratischen
parteien nicht mal sagen warum er als
undemokratisch sind ja aber es stört
mich nicht entsprechend aber schon
richtig wie der behandelt sagt ist eine
pseudo diskussion weil von fd sich
dieses wie gesagt wurden wir werden als
juniorpartner in irgendeine koalition
gehen okay dann haben wir das auch
geklärt und es gab tatsächlich gerade
die erste hochrechnung versuch die
zahlen jetzt mal auf die schnelle noch
mal zusammen zu bekommen die haben
gezeigt für die union 24,7 prozent für
die spd 24,9 prozent ist zeigt sie also
weiterhin ein sehr sehr dichtes ergebnis
oder zumindest eine sehr dichte dichtes
rennen nach vorne dann haben wir die
grünen die hatten 14,8 prozent in dieser
hochrechnung der ersten die linken
liegen weiterhin bei fünf prozent die
fdp war bei 11,2 prozent und die afg in
dem fall bei 11,3 prozent aber es kann
sich auch weiterhin viel viel tun das
wissen wir spannend war übrigens auch
in den in den online diskussionen
schonen oder in den ersten stimmen lars
klingbeil sieht auf jeden fall bei sich
die regierungsbildung das hatte ja diana
von auch schon mal gesagt und wenn wir
auf die union noch mal schauen die csu
dort die hat in bayern tatsächlich
einiges an stimmen verloren ganze 5,3
prozent allein in bayern verloren und
parteienforscher karl-rudolf korte hatte
im zdf gesagt der nicht so ein bisschen
wechselstimmung machtwechsel in der luft
das geht dann ja schon fast würde ich
sagen ja an wen geht es dann vielleicht
estelle machtwechsel könnte ja was mit
den grünen wird zu tun haben siehst du
denn auch schon
gewaltig dass wir wegkommen von der
union und weg von coco
also definitiv also
[Musik]
also ich man sieht es jetzt hier an den
zahlen nicht so aber was du eben gesagt
hast und dass das muss man schon sagen
also die die grünen haben ergebnis mehr
ist oder fast verdoppelt das heißt da
ist ja schon noch mal eine neue strom-
und neuer wind reingekommen und
und auch die diskussionen der letzten
monate haben gezeigt damit da muss was
was neu ist mit rein also eine groko
camp für mich überhaupt nicht mehr in
frage also ich weiß nicht wie es euch
geht aber ich fühle mich auch gar nicht
mehr nach co
von daher wird was buntes und das finde
ich auch schön und da würde ich hier
lese auch recht geben so als querschnitt
der gesellschaft neue und die
gesellschaft ist bunt und ja also
von daher machtwechsel neue aufwind was
neues frisches auf jeden fall
alles ja dann gebe ich das ganze auch
noch mal an dich rüber riechst du auch
den machtwechsel
knapp nein sich nicht und
dann und dann kommt noch mal eine frage
und das leitet vielleicht zu einer ganz
spannenden letzte runde auch bei uns ein
bisschen ein nämlich was hat eigentlich
100 tage wallstraße mit euch gemacht und
gregor fragt was macht es eigentlich mit
zu einem normalen bürger mit jemandem
quasi von der straße wenn ihr 100 tage
euch so intensiv mit politik eigentlich
befasst habt habt ihr jetzt neuen
blickwinkel bekommen oder sagt jetzt zum
beispiel auch erstmal politik
urlaub hab da alles schon gemacht da
wird bei dürften euch auch begleiten
aber von der politik mache ich jetzt
erstmal ein paar tage urlaub und lasse
mir vielleicht nicht jede schlagzeile zu
den koalitionsverhandlungen durch wie
sieht das bei euch aus büren
die letzten 100 tage waren definitiv
intensiv
wir haben über vieles diskutiert
ich würde jetzt nicht sagen ich
beschäftige mich jetzt überhaupt nicht
mehr mit politik sicherlich nicht mehr
so intensiv in den letzten hundert tagen
was ich für mich auch so raus gefunden
habe ist das glaube ich einfach viele
politiker ein ja nicht mehr wirklich an
der basis sind zumindest die
spitzenpolitiker dass die einfach in
ihrer blase leben und
der normale wähler gar nicht mehr
erreicht wird und das wäre glaube ich
auch was wo die politik ansetzen müsste
um einfach wieder ein bisschen mehr
authentischer zu werden und den normalen
bürger quasi zu erreichen
kann ich nur zustimmen ganz klar also
die man hat ganz klar gesehen an diesen
battles die da stattgefunden haben das
doch die entfernung der politik und der
realität sehr sehr groß ist und sehr
sehr groß und auch das wort nachhaltig
zu benutzen weil ich eigentlich nicht so
gerne auch nachhaltig sehr groß ist man
muss sich überlegen wie man näher an die
bevölkerung ankommt wie man sich besser
austauschen kann ich glaube schon auch
das thema das wir jetzt im bundestag was
sie durch die überhangmandate noch mal
mehr leute bekommen und ich glaube dass
das alles nicht im sinne des erfinders
ist da muss einiges angesetzt werden
aber im grunde genommen ich wird im
gehirn letzten satz recht geben da muss
mehr passieren aber
ich wollte noch mal zur frage
zurückkommen
wahlstraße und und politik und also ich
fand das sehr interessant und ich werde
auch weiterhin
darüber informiert bleiben wollen auch
einfach um zu gucken was machen die
jetzt und gerade koalitionsverhandlungen
also gerade jetzt für die grünen ist das
ja mehr gespannt
wie der mir keiner sagt also da müssen
themen die sind dann kompromisslos und
die die müssen gesetz wären also ich
bleibt weiter dran ich finde es
interessant und ich finde auch dass man
dass man immer zwischendurch auch klar
dabei bleiben sollten und andere formate
braucht
ja also bei mir war es auch sehr ähnlich
ich habe mich also ich würde sagen ich
beschäftige mich sonst auch eigentlich
genauso viel mit politik nur jetzt
wahrheit sehr unterschied dass man sich
auch mit super vielen leuten unterhalten
hat außerhalb der eigenen politischen
blase
und ich glaube das spannendste also die
koalitionsverhandlungen die kommen jetzt
noch
und aber also morgen werde ich
hoffentlich erst mal eine politik pause
einlegen gleich zur wahlparty aber ich
glaube wenn man in der partei ist kann
man politik nie ganz ausschließen
[Musik]
weiter beobachten aber nicht so intensiv
wie letzten 100 tage waren doch recht
intensiv ich glaube ich sage es noch nie
in frankreich am meer mit ein glas wein
hand und hat mir aktuelle schlagzeilen
durchgelesen und vier ja
ja also relativ einig seid ihr euch das
ist ja vielleicht ein bisschen ein
bisschen ruhiger für euch persönlich
wert während jetzt natürlich nach der
wahl ja die eigentliche oder den dir der
nächste schritt beginnt die nächste
phase der arbeit was mögliche koalition
angeht da werden wir natürlich auch
weiter
ja das wäre weiter im auge behalten wir
alle glaube ich ich glaube die pause die
sag ich mal gegönnt nach 100 tagen
intensiven austausch
vielen dank auch fürs zuschauen heute
bei uns im youtube live stream uns hat
es große freude gemacht
sowohl analog wie auch also analog wie
digital
vielen vielen dank dass ihr euch so
fleißig beteiligt habt so fleißig im
chat dabei war an der umfrage beteiligt
hat macht das gerne weiter wir haben ja
wir haben es heute ganz oft erwähnt
einen neuen instagram kanal phoenix
unterstrich de den haben diese fünf plus
dieser die die linke gewählt hat in den
letzten hundert tagen schon sehr sehr
fleißig gespielt aber wir hören damit
nicht auf ihr habt eure pause verdient
wir machen aber weiter von daher folgt
uns da sehr gerne und ja vielen dank
aber auch vielen dank an die vielen dank
an euch es war ein fest dank an euch
sagte matthias ja einen guten wahlabend
noch so bleibt spannend also ich es
bleibt spannend so ein schönes gesicht
gelacht das glas ist sozusagen
schaltet gerne auch im livestream jetzt
von phoenix den gibt es auch weiterhin
auf youtube da gibt es alle bilder aus
dem tv armin laschet rede gerade
kanzlerin ist dabei auch alle anderen
spitzen werden wahrscheinlich noch reden
und das könnt ihr persönlich sehen
schön
dass kinder steine waren
ja so aus meinem kinderzimmer